Wait, what? Wait. Wait, what? Wait, huh? Wait. What did What
did you just say? Wait, what did you just say?
Wait, what? Wait.
Yeah, that's something I've never never uttered to anybody.
Dude, you're so Girl, you're so hot. You're so hot. You look
15.
Pardon me? Hello? Huh?
>> So, if anybody hasn't been following, um Turkey Tom
seems to have
got himself in a bit of trouble, okay? Got himself in a bit of
trouble. If I am to understand the allegations correctly, it
seems a little weird. It seems like it's his most recent partner
who originally goes to Kiwi Farms and starts these leaks off.
Basically, Turkey Tom started dating a
uh 7 months ago. Uh so, that'll be in I think June, July. He
was dating this girl. It was kind of serious. And then, he cheated
on her.
And she decided that he was over. It was over It's over for him,
okay? It's No No more Tom. Tom don't Tom don't exist no more.
So, she leaked a bunch of stuff in very embarrassing details.
And I don't think she makes like overt allegations. It's like
she's got some allegations. The allegations to sum them up entirely,
like the serious ones are that he's, you know, physically abusive
during Right? Like, that's essentially And then, possibly some
stuff around blackmail, like he has a blackmail folder on his
computer to keep his old exes quiet. How bad is the recording?
It's again physical like physically abusive or or too physically
um
like possibly sadistic during
that he like hurts girls and then they say, "Please stop." and
he's not necessarily stopping.
Punching drywall is the male BPD equivalent? It is. It is.
Okay, hold on. I made a I made a little drawing, okay? Here's
all our players. Well, here's almost all of our players, okay?
We've got maybe one other person we could put in here, but these
are our players for the Turkey Tom allegations,
So, this We don't have a picture of the girl he was dating.
There are pictures of her with Tom where she's blurred out. So,
this is the original leaker. I only have their avatar cute. They
They just took the default Kiwi Farms avatar, it seems like.
Met Turkey Tom at some dating apps. They seem to be kind of fooling
around a little bit. This is one of the people I believe Tom
was cheating with. This is Creepy Hoarder. I believe this is
This is one of the big issues that this girl had, okay? This
Sacramento girl was that Tom was talking to this person. And
then, apparently,
this person had pictures of Tom, all right?
Maybe possibly pictures of Tom. And they said they got hacked.
And then, it Somehow those pics ended up in like Tom's family's
Facebook feeds or messages or something, okay?
Now, this one's going to be a little bit of a section in and
of itself because I would say on the on the nebulous allegation
front and possibly the thing people are going to make the biggest
deal out of is that it seems
pretty clear
to me, at least,
that Tom's got a bit of an age play kink, okay? Tom likes his
girls to act like little girls.
He gets off on that. There's something there for him. He enjoys
that. That's probably the biggest one. Now, you can engage with
that as an adult, possibly.
Dude Dude, this girl's pictures are very
Very How little we talking? Well, here's a picture of this girl
from 21 21 2022 where she's trying to look as young as possible.
I haven't seen anything strong on this, but I think this person's
in their 30s.
So, very strange, possibly.
Okay? There's another girl involved who dated Tom
um in the somewhat recent past. This girl, Clorox Katie.
All right? She'll be left for dead when we look at the posts.
All right? Now, this person was involved with some people who
were adjacent to Fishtank. And apparently, she helped out in
getting Jet Neptune canceled in terms of his allegations with
Fishtank. She wasn't one of the people making the allegations,
but she was involved. One other major player we need to discuss
is Kai, Tom's long-term ex-girlfriend that he moved to Canada
to live with. Current girlfriend of Larx or Liam Donovan, the
music YouTuber, okay?
So, I I talked about the serious allegations, okay?
I've heard we have another consent violator. Okay, yes. Let's
go through most serious most serious most real to like just embarrassing.
Not in terms of severity or what people make fun of, but most
real and and concerning. So, there are allegations of physical
abuse and physical abuse during sex, I think is I I It might
all be physical abuse during sex, okay?
There are allegations
that Tom pulls his phone out during sex and records without asking
for
Not in a way that he's trying to hide, but in a way that like
he'll pull his phone out and he won't be hiding it. And it'll
take, you know, 30 seconds or something for his partner to know
that he started filming it like sex.
Okay? Very bad. Very bad. Very bad.
with allegations like that, it's very difficult to get proof.
For proof, we'd be looking for things like contemporaneous messages
like somebody chastising him over text about it, right? That's
what you probably be looking for. The implication from the blackmail
folder, by the way. And then, the Yeah, I guess next down from
that is probably the blackmail folder. He apparently has blackmail
on his ex on Kai and some of his other exes to stay quiet, not
talk about his eccentricities
after breakups, okay? And apparently, he bragged about this to
the girl he was most recently. Like, after that, we get
we get into less serious, but more embarrassing. We get into
the age play kink, which is pretty gross and weird, okay? We
get into the fact that this guy like couldn't get off without
watching
Right? Uh multiple women apparently have reported this that he
has to watch porn to get off. So, there I mean, there are other
implications here, okay? So, the stop We've got the stop gooning
hat. We've got like this whole brand he engaged in. Now, to me,
there's like a couple things I'm not certain of here,
Now, I thought, personally, that maybe this was his own thing
where he had the stop gooning brand. He started doing all these
things because he didn't feel like he made good decisions earlier.
I thought that. But now that I'm reviewing the timeline, it seems
like he actually started getting back into gooning. He was messaging
this Belle Delphine look-alike, the uh this girl over here, okay?
He's messaging this girl over here into 2025 and 2026. Well,
maybe not 2026, but into
So, like what the hell, man?
Where was the stop Where was the stopping of the gooning? Okay,
so without further ado, I think, you know, we filibustered long
enough. We got a lot of people in.
Almost 300 people on the stream already.
Let's check it out. So, Sacramento,
January 14th, 2026. We've got these original Sacramento post,
okay?
This is the original Sacramento post.
This is yesterday, 6:46 p.m. In the evening, Turkey Tom got allegations.
Uh an ex of Turkey Tom went to Kiwi Farms yesterday, got validated
by the administrator of Kiwi Farms, Dell, by like emailing him
or something, and started posting, started dumping a bunch of
stuff about Turkey Tom.
These are the Turkey Tom files, okay? So, let's start getting
into it. Hi, Kiwi people.
I dated Tom for a few months after meeting him on Tinder. I'm
not super into internet stuff. Uh we will find out. I believe
I'm more or less ready to say that that's a total
Like, if you get Once we get start getting through this, okay?
You'll start to realize that this person
is almost certainly lying. When they say they they're not online,
when they say they didn't know who Tom was when they matched
with them, cuz that's what they'll say. I don't I didn't even
know who Tom was when I matched with him. It's like, yeah, sure.
Yeah, okay. Okay. Okay,
I do think that this person got into all of this,
pretty quickly that Tom wasn't who they thought they were, and
I I don't know. Literally doing this on Kiwi Farms. Well, this
They're going to explain why they know what Kiwi Farms is, but
we'll keep reading here.
I'm not super into internet stuff and had no idea what Kiwi Farms
was. But this page was always his number one search Safari thing
that pops up on iPhone when he went to Google Google something.
When I asked about this website, he got super defensive and weird
about it. So, I obviously looked into it and found all this crazy
[__] Like him admitting to be being
Question mark? Which like I actually didn't know.
Is he really bi Is he really bi
Cuz like that does make the whole Dude, there's no way
There's no way like memes start to shape reality after a while.
There's no way There's no way that he is the guy. There's no
way.
Can we get Can we get Dude, I'm Ah.
I would never ever direct people to those videos, okay? Never
This is him saying he's bi.
Oh God, really? Really, man? No, I even as someone who is attracted
to males, I find that show repulsive.
What? Um Wait, are you gay? I'm not bi, but for him, bi. Like,
what is Tom doing? That's not Tom's brand. I'm bi, but I hate
using that word cuz it's disgusting. But yeah.
>> Okay. I just I just hate it. It's like "Hey everyone,
I'm bi." Just so you know. >> a it's just like a dictionary
definition descriptor word of your s- It's interesting, but just
every every context I've heard it in is either in someone's Twitter
bio or
well really just that. Is this 15-year-old Tom? Yeah, it might
be. This might be Tom as it's very possible we're listening to
Tom talk about this as like a minor here.
Like this looks like very old pictures of all these people.
It does seem like he's very he's a lot younger when he's saying
this.
He's always pretty open about it. I'll take your word for it,
for Stacia. I I believe you'd know. I do believe that. I think
people just assumed it was memes. This is the owner of this website,
Joshua Moon, to get the code to post here.
Okay. Basically, I started to get suspicious about all the e-girls
he's followed/interacted with and he started raging at me. I
could see that. Hey, why are you Why are you Why are you messaging
that that dog girl? Why are you messaging that like Belle Delphine
look-alike? Why are you messaging all these people? Uh not into
internet stuff, go straight to Kiwi Farms. That is obviously
a hole, but I will say she's trying to explain it. She's trying
to give a reason by saying that Tom looked at Kiwi Farms a lot,
which we all know has to be true given how much he pulled narratives
directly from Kiwi Farms, okay? That has to be true. All
No to DM null. Well,
Yeah, I think
I I'd handicap it at like nine to one. Like nine to one. Like
90% chance that she just straight up was super online, knew exactly
who Tom was, knew what Kiwi Farms was, and just went to a Kiwi
Farms, right?
I I would say. There's like a small outside chance that she didn't
that she didn't and she just like she did find it through Tom
and then she looked it up and then she decided to start engaging
more. Anyway, keep reading.
Uh so he also Tom also first lied to her but the fact that he
does YouTube. He did some crazy like kicked holes in a wall at
a house he was renting cuz some e-girl who copies Belle Delphine
got hacked and the quote-unquote hacker was blackmailing him
with dick pics. He continued to talk with her after the fact.
I have more screenshots confirming all of this. Attached a couple,
but I think I have more. Okay, now the very
very funny thing here is to me. Let's keep Let's keep reading.
So actually, this is another weird one is Tom apparently kicked
holes in walls. Now again, I haven't seen the pictures of that
yet,
but that doesn't seem like crazy, but it is obviously indicative
of like a not mentally well person. Uh sounds like he was getting
blackmailed. That sounds [__] up. I do wonder what
he got blackmailed for
it's not like these leaks went public or something, right? I
do wonder how he got blackmailed exactly by someone who would
have like hacked his All right. We keep
Screenshots confirming. This guy is a real freak and likes to
record encounters without asking first during almost every time.
Very bad. I know for a fact he's done this to at least one of
the girl. Serial gooner, quote-unquote, and has flown out several
e-girls to sleep with. He told me he has a file on his computer
called just in case that's basically voice memos or calls from
his exes to blackmail them in case they ever say something about
him.
But dude, I can't imagine like saving that stuff. I I really
can't.
Like oh, I'm going to like
at the point where you immediately at the point where you're
like I think I have to start recording stuff to make sure I can
get out safely. It's like at that point
and end it and just be like I'm sorry this didn't work out. Cuz
to me, what I what I think happens there is if you can't do that,
then basically you think why did something bad and I don't have
proof of them doing something bad, so I can't end it yet. I've
got to wait to record stuff so I can get stuff on them so that
they can't rat on me, right? Like I Just if you think you have
to do that, you just walk away from the relationship, right?
You're a famous YouTuber, this is a must it seems. Yeah, I I
don't think so. Ultimately, if you're a famous YouTuber and you
get an allegation against you,
if there is no material weight to that allegation, you can Like
I've seen allegations now with a ton of material weight to them
that people can just walk past, right? So realistically, I just
don't think there's ever a need to do this. I think it's just
total
Your attack quiet. Am I attack quiet? I might be getting away
from my mic a little bit. Hold on. Let me pop up voice meter.
I'll turn this up just a touch.
That should make me quite a bit louder. I hope that's not like
awful. Is that terrible for you guys?
Or is that just better?
Better worse better worse better Okay, got it. Cool cool cool
cool. So yeah, blackmail. So basically just voice memos and call
memos and calls from his exes to blackmail them uh with in case
they ever say something about him. Thought I would get the message
out and confirm y'all's suspicion. Also, if this dude if this
gets out to warn other young women in the Texas area about this
dude. So again, I do believe most of the calls would be with
this girl. I do believe
Tom and this girl dated for like three years, I think, including
her like cheating on him with with Lyrics or or basically I think
they probably both cheated on each other and
like Lyrics, Liam Donovan. Uh there were some allegations that
like this guy kind Tom. I do believe the new girlfriend, this
girl, sorry, the Sacramento person leaks that Tom did in fact
get cheated on by by Kai with Lyrics.
Okay, I should have I should have added a Liam Donovan thing
in here, but
Kai did cheat on Turkey Tom with Lyrics and then Turkey Tom took
her back. Yeah, people don't just don't really care. This is
true. People don't really care, man. They just don't give a [__]
They could have both cheated with Lyrics. I guess so.
>> This is I thought Dude, I thought Tom's only path forward
in 2026 was letting Lyrics transition
and then taking his manhood back, okay?
I'm not going to explain how, but you know what I'm saying. I
thought that was his path. Now I don't know what his path back
is. Now 2026 has started off totally differently. Now it's [__]
Damn. Yeah, well we got confirmation of this stuff, but I'm guessing
that during this whole thing where they had that triangle going
on, I'm guessing there's some really [__] messages
back and forth between these people. I'm guessing I'm guessing
is
and that
both of them have like
dynamite on each other for online reputation purposes, right?
But I I could just see given that, you know, there's a love triangle,
she cheated on Tom with another big YouTuber, she
and then Tom took her back. I'm just dude, I'm just guessing
there's like tons. There's just so much tender there.
Played Ark Raiders yet? No. Don't care to.
All right. Anyway,
so we're through the first post. She posts this picture of them
together. This is them in Texas together, I guess.
And then some DMs.
Uh okay. So Tom must have been upset. These are texts from him.
Everything good? I don't know. I'll explain later. It has nothing
to do with you. Oh [__] Scale one to 10, how bad?
Bad. Or How to How bad on a scale one to 10? Very bad. Very very
Um I saw I saw Chud's coverage on this and I he was like oh,
well if it's very bad, doesn't that mean that like clearly there's
some weight to these allegations? And I don't think so.
I think Tom is upset because
his dick pics got sent to his family. That's what's catastrophic.
It's not like oh, very bad as in the allegations could be very
bad or somebody's blackmailing me something very bad. It's like
no, I think it's very bad as in he's pissed because his family
got sent pictures of his [__]
When was the last time Tom was on this stream? A long time ago.
Very bad could mean very embarrassing. Yeah, I just I don't think
this lends any weight to any of the other allegations, to be
honest with you. I I disagree on that. I totally disagree on
that. Okay. An ex of mine basically I An ex of mine got hacked.
And some stuff is probably going to be dropped online. Photos,
they email my family. Oh bro, it's okay. Is it? I have no idea.
It's never happened to me. Dude, this sucks at consoling. Bro,
it's okay. Is it though? I don't know. Never happened to me.
What the [__]
Uh so the fact that more stuff dropping online. Uh you'd have
to imagine if it's just pictures of his dick, that's like not
that bad. I would say there's probably some worse stuff there,
right? Honestly, I'm guessing because it's the Belle Delphine
girl that got hacked, I'm guessing there's some age play going
on there. I'm guessing that's really what's more for him in terms
of going online is it's one thing to hear from multiple sources
that Tom likes his his women to act like little girls.
Right? It's one thing to hear that from multiple sources. It's
another
to see the texts, okay? To see And
Listen, you can't have communication with somebody that doesn't
seem cringe in text in any recording. It will It can always be
played off as cringe. It will always sound bad to anybody else,
okay?
But I'm guessing his DDLG
fantasy texts are going to be explicitly like worse.
And I I will say that's also because Tom himself loves to take
stuff like that, people people having like anything
like like age play stuff. I I think he does a video on like um
like diaper fetishes as well. And he does like to imply like
a direct connection to pedo. A direct connection to you're going
to harm kids, right? Tom does that a lot.
A
And so when it comes out from multiple sources that he likes
his his girls to act like little little little itty bitty little
girls,
it's kind of weird, okay?
Apologize to Mr. Girl. The funny thing is is
people will say oh, it's Mr. Girl. People will try to make that
point now. The Mr. Girl video was bad and Tom does that and Tom
shouldn't do that and and that they'll use it to feel like less
bad about this stuff. But, it's like all that [__]
His video Mr. Girl was bad when he made it. It was really bad
when he made it.
It's just It doesn't matter when it's Mr. Girl. Mr. Girl's like
Mr. Girl and Sneako are like the two people on the internet who
you can just like
and everybody will clap for you. Oh, and Mitch Jones. Sneako,
Mitch Jones, Mr. Girl. These are the three people you can say
anything to them, you can do anything to them, and every single
person on the internet will just like clap for you. They'll just
be like, "Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes." Never tell the truth about these
people. It doesn't matter. It's uh rough. And Hasan? No, Hasan's
got enough of a community that it doesn't happen to him as much.
With Sneako, he just gets ripped. With Mr. Girl, he just kind
of gets ripped. It's pretty unfortunate. Mis Gift now? Um Yeah,
but Mis Gift Sorry, I'm trying to differentiate between people
who like Maybe I shouldn't even throw Sneako in there. It's like
people who haven't really done something that bad.
That's more what it is. Okay, so we're going to continue these
texts. Is she the one who looks like Belle Delphine? Wait, what
does this say here? I'm glad you don't do that anymore. LOL.
Oh, cuz Oh, hold on.
Cuz he would have been saying like, "Oh, I was this person."
Is she the one who looks like Belle Delphine? Yeah, that's the
one. LOL. Yeah. Do you think my type is Belle Delphine? LMAO.
No, like emo hoes of that nature.
I would prefer you just dress normal, to be honest. I don't want
to be that with them anymore. It's better this way.
>> Dude. How Dude, this guy was so committed to like the
goth girls. What
He's like hyper committed. Dude, he's like somebody cutting himself
off from
Uh I have to give them up. It's better this way. It's just better
this way.
Yeah. This [__] does make me want to end hero a little
bit, but it's fine. I must count my blessings.
Bruh. End hero is old. Dude, you can tell this guy was on the
internet when he was like 10.
What does that mean? Keep myself. Not really, but like damn,
this is stressful and gay.
Okay, so these are the first texts that drop is just him talking
about the leaks that happened. And this is again, I believe quite
recent.
Being led to believe this is 2025,
which
is a little weird. I don't know. Is Tom not doing
Tom was like hitting the gym. Looks like he got a little huskier
here, which you know, that happens.
I don't hope he's not getting huskier in his off time. What are
you What are you doing, man? He was in way better shape than
this, right? Like he got quite skinny. I think. I think he got
quite cut up at some point. Am I crazy? I thought he got pretty
low body fat, man. He's He's at a real disadvantage, though,
cuz >> I I remember um he like he got really low body fat
and he still looked like he was like 15% body fat in his face.
Like 15, 18, 20% body fat in his face. I think he gets like he
gets like fat in his face when he has any weight on him at all.
No, no, no. I'm saying like he might not be fat here. He gets
like chubby in his face before anywhere else.
It's unlucky. Tom's never Bro, am I crazy or did he have a video
where he like basically had abs?
I'm almost positive he had some video where he was like he did
some meme in his bathroom and he had like abs. No? Was it AI?
I don't think it was.
Yeah, it was some gay video. It was him pretending to be gay.
Anyway, okay. I I could have sworn this was a video I saw, but
he only recently had self-esteem about his face. When he did
the thing with the vegan guy? No, it's him like It was literally
some skit where he was like gay and he was like getting blown
by some dude in his bathroom.
Could have sworn. Could have sworn, man. Could have sworn. All
right. Where are we going next? We're going to continue scrolling
through this.
All right.
So, she starts She continues posting, all right? Someone Someone
replies, "I'm I'm skeptical, though. Him being a little mini
Destiny is a bit on the nose." Response, "I promise all of this
is real. I can post more screenshots, but I'm a little scared
of him coming after me cuz I'm a normal person and he's just
in case file. LOL."
I'm not alleging anything illegal or saying it was revenge porn
or anything. What I meant was he wouldn't ask before and proceed
to take his phone out and activity to film. I sometimes wouldn't
notice till like 15 to 30 seconds after he started filming. I
have no idea if this is illegal or not. But yeah, he wouldn't
ask before. Reach out to an ex-girlfriend of his, he would do
the same thing to her. The blackmail he has on his computer is
phone calls and texts, I believe. Most of them are from his ex-girlfriend
named Kai. Here is a picture of when we matched on Tinder. Don't
have the messages from when we matched anymore. Now, here's the
biggest hint that she really don't know, okay? Wait, hold on.
This entire community, but there is a big difference from publicly
promoting degeneracy and privatized fetish morality, right? I
have no idea. [__] what entire community. Tom's?
Weird. Okay. So, here's the first example of why
it's a little weird that she says she didn't know he was a YouTuber,
wasn't super online, just a normal person.
And when she matched with the guy who's Tom, who's like clearly
Turkey Tom, she took a picture. Why'd she take a picture? This
is Hinge, right?
What? Why'd she take a picture, though? Oh, no, she said it was
Tinder. But either case, uh why'd she take a picture?
Girls be screenshotting matches all the time. That's the excuse
she uses.
Girls be screenshotting matches all the time. I think he means
between the stuff Destiny does. Oh, I already said that it's
not the same, right? That he wasn't trying to do this like he
wasn't There's no evidence of him spreading. There's no evidence
of him like actually, you know, she I I don't think she alleged
she kept recording. It's like um it's quite bad, but it's one
of those things where like maybe he
I don't know what the entirety of the boundaries were like, right?
It is quite bad, though. He shouldn't do this without consent.
It's It's quite bad to not have the screament in place beforehand.
Doesn't this happen like instantly and the page changes?
Uh I don't think so. It says like, "Do you want to send a message?"
Hold on, though.
I just feel like
you think girls take pictures of all of their matches? That's
Maybe they do. But anyway, she took a picture of this match.
It's the first evidence that like maybe she might have known
who he was.
Anyway, more more logs, more posts. What is your main reason
for posting to this thread? Why did you and Tom break up? Also,
post more screenshots. The main reason I'm posting to this thread
is to kind of warn people, mostly women, about this guy. The
reason we broke up is actually because I mentioned this website
to him and that I saw some crazy stuff about him online
his history with e-girls bothered me. Pic is about the Belle
Delphine type girl who's hacked. I'm suspicious of cheating because
he did not block her after the fact and apparently she was still
talking to him. Oh, she's suspicious of cheating. Okay. All right.
Uh what really me off is that I spent a week painting their poker
table and they outside using it as a beer die table.
It is cool.
Is it like nudes or something? This is the thing asking about
what got hacked.
You You can press charges.
Uh like I just have to remember like I just have to remember
I'm a decently pretty girl with a good head on my shoulders and
I have to live my life more life to live. True, a lot more. It'll
be fine. I mean, it could I could figure out who he is. Yeah,
it's like seven pictures of me with my dick out. Oh, okay. So,
that's the whole thing you were being blackmailed with was just
him with his dick out. Damn. Okay.
We keep going. Where do we get to here? All right. Very interesting.
Did he happen to say anything notable to you after the after
you did that? Anything about the reputation of the forum? Were
you specifically the one to break things off or was it Tom?
Also, were you aware of Tom's internet presence before you started
dating him or did you find out about that later? Like I said,
he lied to me about who he was, but I figured it out pretty quickly,
like on our first date. LOL. He said it was weird for a girl
he's dating to look at gossip at a gossip website. Told me before
I should never look him up online. LOL. The breakup was kind
of mutual, but also I sort of crashed out on him about his past
with e-girls and the dick pic thing. So, I understand it. He
could probably use my mini crash out during this during and right
after our breakup against me, but everything I said was truthful.
Do you have any evidence he flew out e-girls to sleep with? Did
he tell you Did he tell you this or did you discover this somehow?
Was it during your
Told me this. It was before our relationship, to my knowledge,
not during. He was telling me to be careful about texting stuff,
but I reached out to one of his exes and exes I knew.
Sorry. Exes I knew he was with. She's like an e-girl type and
she confirmed. She has more evidence than I do. Sent me pictures
of her face being bruised after going to meet up with him. Oof.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Dude, that's That would be bad, right? Why Why is her face bruised
up? Why her face bruised up, though? What's going on there, man?
What's going on there? So,
All right, we keep going. We keep going. We keep going. Oh, this
gets us into
Okay, so she starts referring to this other girl. This is Katie.
This is Clorox Katie, who we remember from this. She is another
girl who got flown out by Tom or flew herself out, either one.
And she's the one who says her face got bruised and that Tom's
like violent drinks. She has a lot more details here, okay? So,
this is a screenshot from her
Yeah, this is a screenshot from her Instagram story as she's
leaving San Francisco or arriving home to San Francisco, either
one. March 15th, I believe this is after she went to see
So, hold on. Let's read the post first.
I'm denying the old allegations cuz I'm in my early 20s. I don't
know
what that's referring to. 89 the username. Are you 37 dating
Turkey Tom and you come to warn other women? I've been in contact
with the ex since Tom and I broke up, yes. And she's aware that
I'm Oh.
I see. Old allegations. The old allegations as in are you old?
Are you old? Are you an old person? I got it. I got I was [__]
up. That's what it was. Are you old? All right. I've been in
contact with the ex since Tom and I broke up, yes. And she's
aware that I'm posting on here and is actively trying to make
an account to post on here as well and gave me permission to
post these screenshots. Her Instagram is CloroxKatie.
After leaving his house and flying back home, had a big bruise.
Twin a victim. So she That's the bruise on her face right there.
Uh DMs with Tom, she gave me permission to post proof he flew
e-girls
Okay. Hope you have a good flight. Tell everyone on the plane
I said hi. They'll know me. That's so true. And they will clap
and cheer when they hear your name. Taking off. I'm so excited.
9 hours. I know, so excited. Got kicked out of FurryCon.
Security wanted to fight. That was so fast. Holy [__]
Bro, she's the one who exposed Jet Neptune. I think she helped,
right? She helped expose Jet Neptune.
Nice leggings. Thank you. Yeah, they were insane.
Oh, this is the FurryCon people. Did they know you already?
Uh did they already know who you were? Or did they just immediately
get mad when you said something crazy lol? Said something crazy
lol. They told me I needed seven vaccines to be there and I said,
"Okay, I'll leave." and then didn't. No, they didn't.
Bro, this is seven? Yeah, he meant literally seven. For sure.
Got you. Yeah, best to just not say anything. Let them speculate
on what the truth may be. My lips are sealed. It's less about
like me getting [__] I just don't want you to end
up on KiwiFarms pages. lol, I don't think I will. That's not
like I don't think I will. That's not like those type of people.
This type of people? It's just locals talking [__]
to each other. So I'm not worried in that sense. They don't even
know forums how forums work lol. I'm sorry they DM'd you. That
is so odd. It's all good. Just wanted to know what's up haha,
but I'm fine. Oh, I do think this is more
Do we have a date on this one? That seems slightly out of order,
right? That this is somebody who's like coming to see him or
had already seen him.
What did Jet Neptune do? I actually don't know. That bruise looks
like she got backhanded. That bruise is not in a place that looks
like it would occur naturally during sex.
It doesn't.
I Sorry, naturally without an agreement that uh slapping somebody
in the face is
Right? This could happen if if you agree that slapping somebody
in the face is okay. And some people do agree to that. But then
I think she'd be outright lying here, right? Okay, we keep going.
We keep going. So this is a picture of her
Sending Oh, this is Tom flying her out. This is Tom going, "Here's
the Here's your flight." Oof. So he was flying people out.
The time's on the phone.
Oh, does it? 8:22, 8:24.
8:23. Oh, these are just really out of order. I see. I see.
They're just really out of order. Okay. Do we do this one first?
So the flight was there.
Oh, these are when she's screenshotting,
They're not necessarily out of order. Hold on.
They're not necessarily out of order. They're just the order
she put them in, it looks like. Or
I can't tell. In any case, I don't think the
I don't think what they're actually talking about here is all
that relevant. It's just basically proof that she was getting
flown out. Okay. Oh, good question. I got one way. How many days
can you stay? All right. Also, how many days I need to tell my
boss I'll be disappearing. Okay. That's really all this is. Got
it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Replying
to KiwiFarmers. More.
Uh has he ever dated any of those age play girls? I saw him follow
a couple a while ago. The girl he sent the dick pics to and got
hacked was an age play  Belle Delphine type of girl. I
sent the screenshots about the blackmailer guy here earlier.
He told me he want went to meet up with her, but was too weirded
out and went back home. Her account has been posted in this thread
before. I believe it's
So this is Null saying he's confirmed the identity right here.
This creepyhoarder person is very weird. They are a very weird
account to follow and then go to meet.
Listen, I went to meet her and then I just we didn't do anything
and then I just went back home.
J sock with a brain brain rot takes. Like what? Wideo03?
Hop in the Discord if you got a problem, bro. What's the What's
the brain rot take here? Yeah, no [__] homies. No
[__] The take of reading these DMs is uh yeah, really
bad.
Just brain rot, man. Okay. Well, anyway, who is creepyhoarder?
Uh this is creepyhoarder. It's this girl who's taken these screenshots.
She's got a couple different She's got another at as well that
I've got here. Hold on. It's creepyhoarder or ShiroUS ShiroUSA
ShiroSa 999.
Okay. An age play account that basically acts like a tiny itty-bitty
little girl. Okay. Gross. Gross. Uncensored version here. I don't
need that. I'm good. Although I don't I don't necessarily think
there's anything wrong. And the big thing we see in in her tags
on Instagram, okay?
Is what does she have? She got cute curl cute core. I think there's
another one with like kid core, right?
I don't think I see that one here. There are tags on one of these
that's like kid core, which is very very very weird.
Blahaj is 100% age play coded. Okay. Or blahaj blahaj. What What
does that even mean? In any case, she does age play. Like she
literally I It definitely says kid core in a couple of her takes
in other places, even if it doesn't right here. Oh, shark in
Swedish? Oh.
Oh, the stuff shark animal. Dude, it's
Brother, I There are more pictures, okay? We could go on a deep
dive with this person. There are like more pictures. There's
more stuff on this
I think we're good, okay? We're good. We don't have to do more.
We've proven our
Nothing else has to be proven here, okay? More posts. More leaks.
Were you aware of who he was before you started dating? Seeing
as you screenshotted your Tinder match. Like what did you What
did his bio say he did for a living? Did he ever physically abuse
you? You said he was a gooner. Was he a freak with specific kinks
like he wanted you Dude, I will say the people who post and ask
all the questions, I'm always a little bit like, did you got
I understand why you're doing it, okay?
It feels a little
It's like over the top with some of the questions. They have
Some people immediately are like,
How does guy [__] How does guy [__] That's
like the first question they ask. How does guy [__]
[__] It's like Man, I get why I get why you do that.
I get that that's like the most embarrassing [__]
I was wrong. You're vindicated. He posted this at some point.
What is it? Yeah, okay.
Yeah. Sorry, this was Tom at one point.
He got like pretty low body fat. It's not like a big deal, but
you think that's sub 15? I think that's possible. That's getting
close. Yeah.
That's definitely getting close to 15. That's like 19.
Okay. Skinny fat? Well, it is He looks kind of skinny fat because
this guy doesn't actually go to the gym. This guy goes to the
gym and only works his upper body.
So yeah, he's not going to get stocky. He's not going to build
up like effectively. His arms look so out of place. Dude, he
looks like
He looks so goofy, right? Like he just builds arms, chest. He
just does like arms, chest when he goes to the gym.
Arms, chest. Arms, chest. Arms, chest.
Didn't he say Wasn't there a point where Tom benched more than
he squatted? I think that's a thing with Tom.
That he like literally benched more than he squatted.
Which is crazy. Some wild stuff, man. Okay, let's keep looking.
Let's keep looking. Uh his Tinder profile is mostly just pictures
of him flexing, usually his phone covering his face. I won't
get into anything illegal, but during sex he was very rough.
Would choke and hit me in the face. I don't think anyone knew
IRL about this. Okay, so this is two different points, then.
And if he was hitting in the face, which is the allegation that's
out there, I do believe that's where the other bruise would come
from.
Is that where the bruise in the other girl came from? Yes, he
could hit pretty hard. Okay. Well, there you go. Solved. Sorry
to hear that uh Sorry to hear that's what happened to you. Sounds
like a typical addicted gooner. Uh sounds like typical addicted
gooner behavior, though. Does he have a addiction  was
he into harder stuff? And if yes, when did you find out about
it?
He told me he was a addict in the past, but quit a couple years
ago. I believe he replaced his addiction with filming other women
because he was unable He was unable to ejaculate most of the
time during sex, but only through watching the videos he would
take. As soon as I confronted him about it or about what I had
seen about him online, he wasn't able to maintain an and I think
it's just a huge ego thing for him. Oof.
Oof. Dude, like huh. So yeah, bad breakup and she is here to
destroy his ego. She is here to humiliate him on the internet.
Now, I think there's like a lot of other things here going on
that are possibly very bad. But I do think at its core, she could
probably let a lot of it go cuz she spends a lot more time talking
about the things she's she's saying to humiliate him, right?
To like break his to to ruin his reputation online, to Now, but
again, maybe he deserves that in some way. I I'm not really here
to judge that so much, but I'm just saying her motive to me is
a lot more about
punching girls in the face is not
gooner behavior. Slapping girls in the face absolutely is. That
is something that you hear about that men get into that through
watching porn. And they think slapping girls in the face is something
you do naturally during sex. I don't think there's any allegation
that I've seen that he was punching these women in the face.
I think if if he was punching these women in the face, that bruise
is way bigger. Right? That's a different kind of force than a
slap. Has Tom made any comment yet? No, I don't think so. Girls
asked to be slapped in [__] It didn't say above.
It said he could hit pretty hard. Hit me in the face. Hits to
me If if it was punch, you would say punch. Hit me in the face.
This is like the it's behavior he's talking about during like
talking about addiction, that's going to be slapping to me. Um
blank, you need to chill, man. It's not that it's not that big
a deal,
Also, at least 50% of women ask to be
Uh no, in my in my experience, the slapping part is not something
they ask for a lot. I don't think so. I and I'm not saying my
experience I'm talking about like talking to women when they
complain about this. Women don't ask to be slapped that much.
Choking is sure, that's a thing that I think a lot of women do
ask for, but yeah you just
there's a way to naturally work up to the the
like a lot of things during slapping somebody's probably something
you want to check in on. There's nothing there's nothing that
like a interaction faster than going to like that something that
extreme
and then the girl's not into it and it just ruins the whole thing.
Like I don't know. You going to that without any understanding
is kind of bizarre to me. Okay. All right, we keep reading. LOL,
we dated for like 7 months. I met his family. So, let me get
this straight. This guy likes to sleep around and browse kiwi
farms. Some random chick he banged off Tinder is mad he wasn't
looking for anything serious.
We dated it for 7 months. I met his family. Oh, always talk there's
no way Tom is hanging out with those people. Oh, [__]
Is Tom in Sacramento with all the uh
with all of those gun tubers as well? Is that where is that where
Tom is?
Is he in the the you know reformed gooner community?
I'm asking the real question here.
Oh, is it San Antonio? I think he cities up. Wait, Sacramento's
in California, isn't it? Sorry, not American not
I was confusing San Antonio and Sacramento. That's my bad. Not
American. Capital California? Oh, interesting. Didn't know that
either. Didn't know that either, man. Okay, let's
keep on going.
We dated for like 7 months. Okay, can you please provide proof
of the abuse allegations? The allegations of impropriety, etc.
I don't think that it's that hard of an ask. Um wait, what do
you mean? This guy slaps during scenes. Could you post proof
of that?
Probably not.
Especially if this girl didn't like being recorded. That'd probably
be really hard to do.
Could you just post proof right now?
I would say in terms of proof, you're looking for her saying
over text at some point, "Hey, I really don't like the slapping
thing. Could you please stop?" Which I did think there were some
people chastising him for how rough he is later on. Okay.
So, can you post proof? It's hard because he was very careful
about what he said over text. And again, I'm not alleging anything
illegal, just that he would hit and choke because he was a super
gooner. Sort of normalized it in my head, but it's definitely
not okay to do that. All of the proof is in those videos he had.
Refused to send me or ignored the question when I asked. Katie
told me with with the picture of the bruise was due to during
injuries during Which I believe because he would slap both of
us. I'm really sorry, guys. Did you live together during those
7 months? 7 months is a long time. What made you stay if he was
sketchy and had red flags? Did he speak about wanting to start
a family? No, he didn't. We would only see each other like once
a week. He was usually pretty nice, but sometimes would say stuff
that made me question his intentions. Would buy me a lot of stuff
and take me to nice places. Said he wanted to marry me and start
a family, but as soon as I started getting sus, it was like a
switch a switch
Another thing I wanted to confirm that Kai cheating on him with
Liam is 100% real and Tom moved in with her after the That girl
really him up and he would still see about it during our
Oof. I believe it though, okay?
I believe it. If there's one thing we could say for sure about
this Kai girl, it seems like she the tendrils go deep, okay?
There's some demonic goth girl magic that happens and the tendons
go deep. Yeah, sure see is definitely an online term. I I fully
believe she's like an online person. I I is the one that got
away. Hmm, okay. Keep reading. Was he very insecure and controlling
about who you talked to because of this? No, it was almost the
opposite. Like he didn't care if I went out to a bar or anything.
But yeah, his feelings about his ex I think contribute a lot
to his behavior.
How long ago did you date? How long ago was the stuff with Katie
and the age player girl? We dated from May 2025 to the beginning
of this month. Katie and the age player was in 2024.
Ah,
see that to me kind of seals it on the stop gooning stuff. Like
when you're gooning that heavily and you got the stop gooning
brand, I think that's uh that's false advertising, bro. So, Tom
Tom made this whole this whole brand cuz when he's going to like
when he's going to wake up in the morning and brush his teeth,
he puts the hat on. He's like, "Right. Right. Do not right."
Just a consistent reminder to himself, okay? Queenman is lucky
this drama popped up cuz something about him was brewing. Now,
West, you're totally seething in the chat. You're totally by
Queenman. Queenman do. I hope you understand that.
Or post literally anything, but go
Go off, king.
I'm just going to come to chat and make things up.
Very cool, man. You're a cool guy.
All right, we continue. Did he ever try to impose his ex's style
on you? Like buying you clothes that she would wear or ask she
would wear or ask you to change how you wear your makeup. You
mentioned about being surprised about him being bi. Do you know
if any of the e-girls he flew out were not actually
>> Dude, is this guy chaser? This guy suck girl [__]
This guy suck girl [__] Is that This guy suck girl
[__] Trying to imply something? It's made up. Yeah,
I know I know Chud implied that Queenman hellbent. I do know
that. Made up. Yeah, Queenman is
Queenman's like Fuentes in that his will never matter to the
internet.
For as long as Queenman does content, I feel like he's not going
to date
Feel pretty confident. Anyway, on he was on Queenman and Dickers
hooking up. Bro, where why you writing this fan fiction,
uh you thought Queenman you thought Queenman couldn't resist.
Queenman did talk about Listen, I heard a lot of people talking
about how best ass on the trip didn't go to hellbent, it went
to Dickers. Dickers dragging a wagon, okay? Anyone else hearing
this that Dickers be dragging a wagon?
I've heard this from Queenman. I've heard this from multiple
people.
You thought Queenman would just get enticed? You think Queenman's
an ass man? He couldn't resist Dickers?
It's pretty [__] up. Pretty [__] up to
hypothesize, okay? Okay, we need to keep going. So, did he impose
his style on you? Did this guy chase? Did he like No, he would
actually tell me that he liked that I looked normal and he was
done with the BPD types. I think one of the screenshots of our
messages had him saying something like that. I have no idea about
the gender of e-girls. I'm pretty sure they were all women to
my knowledge. Another thing to add, during one of our first dates,
he told me I looked like I was around 15. Told Katie the same
thing. Wait, what? Wait, wait, what? Wait, huh? Wait, what did
what did you just say? Wait, what did you just say?
Wait, what? What?
Yeah, that's something I've never never uttered to anybody.
Dude, you're girl, you're so hot. You're so hot. You look 15.
Pardon me? Hello?
Huh? Jesus.
So, did Tom ever gossip? She's just answering more questions
from people. Did Tom ever gossip about any of his YouTube friends
behind their backs to you or anything like that you remember?
No, not really, but he told me that a lot of YouTube people are
fake. He was on Discord like 24/7. What was the context? Did
he mean it like, "Oh, baby, you looking 15 years old and Tommy
likey." Which is approximately how cringe I imagine he talks
at all times.
Or is it like, "Haha, you look 15." Like kind of a joke.
To be honest, I don't even know how to phrase it in the latter
fashion, but yeah, that sounds hella sus without context. Context
was that I told him he looked older than his age. In response,
he said I looked 15 to 16 because it's real hard to tell at the
ages of 15 to
Uh-huh, that seems like a really specific response. Very interesting.
Very interesting. Okay, this might be too personal, but text
about being hurt and bleeding after sex. I really don't have
much evidence because he was so careful and told me all of this
was
Uh I don't like the told me all of this was normal thing.
I do think that at some point, like if you just keep dating this
guy and you only release this after you break up, but you've
been dating him while he's like rough during sex the whole time
and then you go, "Well, actually uh he made me think it was normal."
No, he didn't. If you didn't like it, you didn't like it.
If you didn't like it, you didn't like it. I think you you have
to tell him that. After a while, it does kind of become normalized.
And like you can criticize him for doing it originally, but after
a while, it's like I don't know.
It's kind of rough.
Is bad synage. Thank you. Yes. Stop gooning. Never goon. Dude,
how do I get this to I need this to not that much. I need to
get it out past the avatar cuz it's the avatar's taking up all
the
There we go. Okay, like we don't really need to do it three times
in one day. Crying faces. Or do it so hard I hurt and bleed.
Dude,
that's rough. Very early in the relationship. We don't we don't
even need to have We don't need to have sex that much. Well,
if you don't want to have as much, we don't got to. We can do
other things. Okay, I like doing the other doing other things,
too. Picture, they're dating. The lobster pinchers will go crazy.
Are you still thinking about coming here over the weekend or
should we wait?
For now, it just depends on how much I can get done Thursday
and Friday. Got to make sure I'm not falling off.
Why did he capitalize falling off like this? Got to make sure
I'm not falling off, guys.
Got to make sure I'm not falling off,
Okay, makes sense. I don't know why I thought you were a conservative.
It doesn't really matter, though. Also, I bleed again.
Also, I did bleed again. Jesus. I'm I'm thinking I need to get
this checked out. Now, when she says she's bleeding, that one
like that one I'm guessing is from like aggressively
like not using lube, not doing foreplay. That's more what it
sounds like when she says bleeding.
Not like she got hit in the face and is
Right? He tried what was gross. So, it sounds like
That could be an of of rough sex, right? Not necessarily, though.
Could just be an indicator of like some
somewhat inconsiderate fellow. Also,
maybe maybe this is crazy. Bleeding does happen sometimes. That
can happen. Doesn't necessarily mean something like horrifying.
That can happen.
Now, I'd say the pattern of it is a little bit. This won't be
quite so big a deal until we get a little bit later on and we
get some recordings. I believe in one of the recordings, somebody
is telling him that like, "Hey, you're like you're you're hitting
too hard or you're you're hurting." We'll have to see um how
consensual those recordings look, by the way, too. I have no
health issue that I know of. Never bled during sex before. It
was a like a It was the aggression. Just gave in to it after
a while and I told him I liked it, but I bled after almost every
single time. Yeah, see, that's the other thing is she says she
likes it. It's like, "Okay, what are we what are we doing?" You
want me to watch the Chud clip? You want me to Turkey Tom's girlfriend?
You like that [__] You like that do you point of
view. You're Turkey Neeko did this so much better. >> Turkey
Tom's girlfriend. You like that do you like a bit of that do
you
Dude. All right. Let's let's take another look. Did he ever get
give Did he ever give you any sort of aftercare or did he just
expect you to get over it yourself? Would just go on his phone
or Discord after literally choking, hitting, and making me bleed,
lol. Had to teach him to be nice after. This was an issue at
the beginning. I believe the bleeding was caused because he would
basically just bend me over, choke me, and stick his dick into
me, basically. Katie had the same story. Reaching out Yeah, see,
a dude. It's It's like it's so easy to understand what it's what's
going on there. So easy to get.
Katie had the same story. Reaching out to me has been helpful
in understanding how bad this all really was because I only had
told my roommate after one time that was pretty rough.
I stopped attempting to reach out to it all since you've registered
and first posted. I told him I was considering reaching out to
law enforcement / telling people about everything that went down
and then I blocked him after listing out every single thing he
did wrong because I know he will send the my text to his lawyer.
Yeah, so
as far as his conduct with this person,
I think outside of the recording, it's seeming like a lot of
this is stuff you can't really I I wouldn't like hang him over
a lot of the other stuff with this person specifically.
It's like the recording is really bad, but with this person in
terms of she said she didn't mind this this kind of like rough
sex.
like he just seems kind of ignorant to the foreplay stuff. I
don't know. It's It's like sounds bad, but a lot of the stuff
with this person seems not anywhere near as bad as it was made
out to be originally. Or not It's not that bad. It's the next
thing the next the next set of allegations. And it's like Okay.
I'm saying not that bad. I'm probably just calibrating against
what I've seen for coverage online so far. Right? Actually, Soapbox,
she's explicitly saying she did consent. Like she's explicitly
saying, "Yeah, it was I told him I liked it." When Chud went
over the Turkey Tom stuff, it sounded like if he found it too
far fetched that Tom would even be on KF a lot for the earlier
point, too.
now, hold on. Chud might have a point there. Who believes that
Turkey Tom would have Kiwi Farms as like the top link in his
phone in 2025?
Bro, there's that his whole research operation, his whole script
writing operation was already written off like already sent to
Mumbai, okay? Like he wasn't doing any of that. All right, that
was totally farmed out to Mumbai. I don't I don't believe that
he would have been looking at any of that stuff in 2025.
Right? That's when this girl saw it.
So, I would say for me, it's like I could believe that.
Tell us about a time he cried, lmao. What? I'm back. Told me
he only cried at Sopranos / movies.
The [__]
Are you being serious? He's been using third world workers? Well,
I don't know about that. He He gets his scripts written for him
by other people. He's just got other researchers. I don't think
they're Indian.
I'm sure they're just people who are on Discord a lot. Oh, okay.
Add Sacramento mentioned a just in case folder. Can you confirm
/ corroborate what would be in that folder? And do you know if
anything related to you is in that folder? And what type of material
it is Oh, is in it. No clue. He told me it was phone calls /
texts from his ex, Kai. I'm probably in there, too, now. Might
be other stuff as well. What did Tom's living space look like?
Was it messy? Did he have empty cans and boxes everywhere? Did
he own anything weird? Dude, this one This one was so weird to
me. This is like just a regular This is like a Turkey Tom fan.
This is like a weird overly obsessed fan who's just like What
was this What was this house like? Was this house messy? By the
way, he had piles of dirty Zyns piled up like little volcanoes.
Yes, empty cans and bottles everywhere. It's like, "Okay.
I could believe that." He's like a young guy who is on the internet
a lot, doesn't really care about the appearance of his place.
But then she posted a picture of his place a little bit later
and I saw it. I posted in my Discord. Let me go grab that picture
right now cuz I was like, "Dude, that's not even bad." His was
like clean, actually.
Hold on. From me. Dude, his place was clean. This is the picture
she posted.
I also didn't look at this to see if there's anything I shouldn't
have on here, but there's Discord and [__] Okay.
Aha. I recognize this avatar.
Wait, is that That's definitely Diorio, right? Right there? That's
definitely Diorio. Who are these people? That looks like Perry's
avatar somehow to me, but
Anyway, yeah, it's like he's got like some Zyns laying out and
then it's literally just clean otherwise. Now,
he must have just moved into this place and like unpacked his
monitors. This is like right after he set his [__]
up. But that was the picture she showed. I'm just like, "What?
That's not even dirty." Anyway, clean except for that cable management.
Yeah. That is desk never? Well, it looks like hold on. But it
looks like he just set up, right? Or I wonder how long he'd been
here for cuz he's literally got the box for his monitor and then
the box for his computer
over here or like this is a hard drive box, but I'm guessing
it's a couple hard drives or something. So, it looks like he
just unboxed his [__]
Right? Monster energy Dude, what a stereotype, though. Monster
energy drinks and Zyns.
Damn. Okay, we keep going. What else we got here? Uh that's battery
and illegal without consent. Are you implying it was
She should report him to the police if she suffered bodily harm.
He would hit and choke without ever asking if this was okay.
And yeah, I'm thinking about it. Probably going to be one of
my last posts on here. When more [__] eventually
comes out about him, just know I warned
I don't think you could go to the police after a 7-month relationship
and say that this guy like hit me during sex and then eventually
I told him I liked it. I Unfortunately, like it does suck cuz
he probably does do something wrong, but I don't know that you
could go to the cops about this, right? I don't think you I I
literally don't think you could. I don't think this is something
you take to the
Maybe the other girl could, but yeah. Anyway, I think that's
the end of her post on day one. She comes back today and posts
more, all right? Now, this is Clorox Katie. This is this girl
in the diagram, okay? So, this girl right here, Clorox Katie.
I believe there's some argument that she should be talking about
how ugly this woman is. I don't particularly care. That's kind
of weird to me, but Tom clearly had a vibe. He clearly had an
aesthetic he was going for all of the time.
Kosher Clorox.
Uh maybe. Kosher Katie. Anyway.
So, we'll look She She eventually starts posting here. Somebody
is saying it's linked to her Instagram, too. Can I pull this
up? Just going to pull up. I can just see this is the This is
what he's going for. Okay, this is Tom's aesthetic. This is dynamic.
It's what he likes. All right, so she first starts posting, okay?
Oh, this is just about who she is. Primary statement. Hi, finally
made an account. Yes, Tom is extremely harsh during sex. I've
been down the kink roads in my life and how he acts is actually
just evil and almost sadistic. Not even kinked up, just actually
a Patrick Bateman type gooner. First girl already posted some
of my screenshots, but if anyone has questions or wants specific
proof, I'll try to see if I can answer. Wait, did I miss the
Oh, no, I didn't miss. No, no, no, I got Those were her her screenshots
about her
her flight. That was the girl who's from the flight logs, okay?
Not literal flight logs, but
Uh these ones? These ones. Yeah. So, these ones were it's like
her This is her talking to Tom and getting flown out, okay? That's
who this girl is.
One more reply from her. He also said it was awesome I looked
like a little girl the first time we had sex. Told me he was
excited to learn I BPD. Shut the [__] up because
with it love harder, lel so real.
That That seems like a weird thing to point out. That seems like
a That seems like a very bizarre thing to to say to somebody.
Oh, I'm so happy you have an a mental illness. It's just a weird
one, okay? That's a weird one for me.
Why are they all like this? I don't know. Who says, "Preferably,
you should drop everything you have on him."
This person responds, "I got to upload everything from my phone
to my PC. I got a crazy audio of him saying he wants to night
me. Oh, boy. For which uh sorry, which for sure think he was
saying that as like negative rizz, but actually insane to use
that as rizz."
as bad as the night like thing sounds like, okay? And it does
sound bad. I don't know if I have the audio recordings in here
or if we just have like a transcription. I've seen a transcription
of that video like floating around.
As bad as it is, it's like a joke. It's a meme. She says it's
a meme.
I don't know, man.
I feel like that's just another embarrassing detail dropped to
maximize
Right? Just get consent. Well, you had consent. It has become
a super fun meme. What the [__] is night room? Tom
I believe starts talking about how he wants to do a night room
on this girl. Yes, there's there's audio logs.
What made you turn on him? Obviously, he's done some [__]
but what moment was it that made you decide this? I just truly
thought he was a cringe F slur who def was going to beat me later
if I stayed around. We only had a two-month fling because even
my insane ass was scared of how he acted and it was also just
stupid. I hated conversation with him. Or he was also just stupid.
I hated conversation with him. What specifically did he do and
what proof do you have? He was just extremely weird to me and
also evil during stream. Again, I only had a small fling with
him and I would have to fly out to see him. So luckily, I didn't
witness a lot, but enough to tell you guys and also help add
validity to her statements. I also have random audio recordings
and every DM and text.
He wasn't paying for your flights? No, he was lol.
Is there anything particularly interesting or damning you'd like
to share from them? I'm turning on my old phone now to grab the
videos and I'll post whatever I think is even semi-relevant.
How did you guys meet? Did he initiate contact with you or vice
versa? I'd already followed him because I watched his YouTube
lol. Then when I when him and Kai broke up, he immediately DM'd
me on Instagram and followed me.
He also told me I looked like Kai and he definitely has some
weird issues relating to her because he still has all her clothes
even after moving multiple times since they broke up. Oh, that's
super bizarre.
Oh, that's really Dude, that's a that is a humiliation thing
and there's no proof of that. That would be very weird if he
kept moving her clothes with him around. That would be bizarre
as [__] Be very strange.
at least so far no smell problems were reported. No, he definitely
smelled also last time I saw him he had ringworm lol.
Come on, man. Who is Kai? This girl better be hot. This is Kai.
Kai's over on the left side of the diagram. That's Kai. That's
Kai I think in the opening of this we might also have Hold on,
let me duplicate here. I think in the opening of this document
we also have some other pictures of Kai. Give me Give me a second.
I'll grab them. Kai, we got an Imgur album of Kai right here.
Let's take a look.
Oh, what the [__]
This page cannot be found. This literally just worked 2 seconds
ago. That really gets taken down? What the
What the [__]
That worked like two I literally clicked on this before streaming
and it worked just fine. Oh, it's taken down now. Weird. Anyway,
there's the pictures there's like one or two other pictures.
There's a picture of like Kai and Lyrix in there. The Kai one
taken down for some reason or not popping up. I have no idea
why. Super odd. Which is weird cuz the Clorox Kitty one still
works.
But whatever. Whatever. So, please don't drip feed. A lot of
others have done exactly that and it was a mistake. I had to
turn on my old phone and upload to my PC. Jesus Christ, I'm getting
horny. I got to turn on my old phone and upload to my PC. Then
here 1 second, please lol. I'll post that audio first. So then
we've got the videos. Now, I don't know how much of this I'm
going to actually pull up on screen. Okay. Here's the Yeah, okay.
Here's the Here's the transcription here. Rubble versions with
cleaned up audio original here.
he used to talk about holding me down and hurting my arms and
me running away. Also night room. Ignore how awkward I sound,
guys. Imagine being on the phone with him.
Unintelligible. That I like put on top of you and like really
put all that weight on you? Question mark.
True, actually true. Did I Did you really like it that wild?
True. Okay, yeah. I mean, you're too strong sometimes. My little
noodle arms I would literally was I thought my arms were going
to break at one point. Yeah, yeah, you know, I'm just blank strong
and
Yeah, true. True, true, true, true. So
It's so nice though. It's like cuz like you're small and petite
and I'm like big and strong. So like we're matched up. It's like
it's a match made in heaven. There it is. There it is. Yeah,
like you have small and I have big and it makes like perfect.
Ain't no way this guy said these things in addition to all the
other stuff. I'm sorry. I do have to point out that this guy's
got an age play thing. There's like an age play thing going on
here. And I'm just like that's very
What that Dude.
That's It's a lot, man. It's a lot. It's the ideal thing is my
thing. I'm still I'm just Yeah, I'm still shocked that you like
my boxes. I do like
the elf girl from like would be like So true. Oh my god. Oh my
god. What's the Skins quote? She like a fairy on acid. Haha.
What's that again? The show Skins blah blah blah blah British
show.
Now, I don't know. Can we listen to the audio from the second
one? These are These seem to be recorded without his like knowledge
I would imagine.
Let me see what the audio's like on this
Oh, wait. Hold on. No, we could we could just watch the video
cuz this is her her being on the phone with him. This is like
a one-sided recording, but it is what it is.
Oh, this is the Sorry, this is the other one. Let's see.
This one's different audio. This is the night room one. Which
I don't have transcription of it, so I'm going to listen.
That's him memeing, okay, obviously.
True, true.
Dude, if you can't hear there's a there's he's she's listening
with like another girl in her like apartment or
who who mouths like, "You're a victim." to her. He's like, "Yeah,
I I like night room. I'm a fan of night room."
I think it's sleep stuff, but I don't
Maybe. Could be. Could be. Could be. Could be.
Hard to say.
Odd, but
that one I'm That one I'm not inclined to be that upset about,
okay? I don't really think that means much.
Here you go. These are some of him talking about holding me down
and hurting my arms with me running away. Also night room. Wait.
Guys, did this work? I'm going to How do you upload a video?
Why were you recording in the first place? Was this before or
after you met? Did you explicitly him for clout to one day expose
him? You're involved in a lot of other e-drama. The Lulu so small
larp is pretty cringe. He's way worse though lol because I'm
so big and strong.
My best friend was at my house and thought I was a victim from
the jump. He was saying stuff So saying similar stuff all call,
so she started recording. At the end of the night you can barely
hear her whisper, "You a victim." lol. I agree I was only playing
a lot playing along because I don't know what else to say. Also,
I talked to him This This person I think does
get
get involved, okay? This person gets involved a lot. This person
I feel like this person is more of like, okay, they've been involved
in exposing multiple people like this. I don't know. I don't
know. I don't know.
Not definitive, but
it is a little weird that she's involved in multiple ones of
these, okay? Also was only involved with Jet stuff because I
don't know, I'm a hot girl online who's in the same evil sphere,
so they tend to orbit me. Abby exposed Jet on my behalf lol over
bitterness. I didn't even know who Ellie was or the whole drama
there. I guess I accidentally opened that wormhole. I wonder
if there's a short video on like the Jet Neptune drama that she
was involved in that we could watch. Just out of curiosity, can
you name a few bands that he listens to? Wage War, Alpha Wolf,
A Day to Remember only bands we had in common. He listened to
a lot of new age slop festival type emo though if that makes
sense. I totally think he had that into him by Kai by the way,
the the new emo stuff. New age slop festival type emo if that
makes sense. I feel like whatever whatever music she's describing
that's like Kai's taste in music.
I I guarantee it.
We should just go see if if Lyrix started listening to whatever
this is. This festival emo I have no idea, man. No, so you're
passed around So you're a passed around e-thot. I never met Jet
IRL or any 4chan freak, but Tom lol.
Besides the age play can you tell us any weird [__]
that he's also into? She dated him longer, so she might have
more insight lol, but to me just weird CNC ass force play again
into small girls and damn near age play. He would just talk a
lot about about a lot.
>> Wait, is that something criticizable now? Oh, it's like
bad to talk about You can't just You just can't talk about Oh,
that's what 2026 is. Now you can't even talk about anymore. Is
that That's the way it is? You can't talk about You can't talk
about I guess we just can't talk about anymore. I guess we're
not allowed to talk about anymore. Okay. Okay. I see how it is.
I thought this was America. Almost the dark humor
>> I have really dark humor. Dude, can somebody can somebody
do that meme? We need that meme for Chud Logic. I think I said
this in his Discord. Hold on. I'm going to go I need to go find
this log from like me I I should go find my logs while I was
watching his debate in his I was watching that debate and like
commenting at Spicy Chud. It was so funny. Hold on. Can I find
this log really quickly?
Oh, yeah. He said to Pisco at one point, "You're signaling to
your DGG audience." Also, you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're Listen, dude.
Wasn't a fan of his strategy in the debate, let's say. I didn't
think he was
The thing to me was the strategy the signaling he was doing was
actually to me weaker than his actual arguments. His actual arguments
were good. Like he had good arguments. He could make good arguments
and he talked about and DGG like so much for no reason.
It like it lessened I think he was like he borderline could have
won without it. I don't even think it was bad occasionally. It
was just like I think he almost
in the true spirit of I think he saw that it was making people
uncomfortable and he just was like, "Oh, that makes you uncomfortable?
Well, let me say it a thousand more times." Anyway. Anyway, okay.
Ba ba ba ba Why didn't you go on tank? This is the women version
of fish tank. Wasn't allowed, various reasons. Kato got on through
me,
That's fish tank reference. I don't get it. Katie needs to work
on her vocabulary. I didn't know how to respond, okay? I know
I stammer, but not that bad.
That's the kind of girl Tom's into who just goes, "True. True.
True. True.
You do like a little night True. So true. That's very true. True.
You like night True. Like
Before the recent fallout have you tried to inform Tom about
the Nep steam files and get him to do a video on it?
Shaddy worked very hard on the case, and it sucks that nobody
cares in the end. No I didn't even want to be involved in that
All Shaddy and Abby were
That was all that it was all Shaddy and Abby being F-slurs.
I think some people are confused. This is Left 4 Dead, aka Clark's
Katie, who's also the woman who helped expose Jet Neptune and
said Chris Lynch sent her $100. She's not the one However, she
doesn't seem too far off. Posting photos of me at an anime con
with then with a Hello Kitty purse isn't close to what these
freak ass hoes do at
Actually, that's true. Uh still eyebrow raising. Thirst trapping
hoes imposing with lollies at anime anime convention full of
leagues above different or leagues different, I'm sure. Perks
of having BPDE. You guys seem mad. Let's focus on what matters
here. I'll be back with more screenshots later.
Okay, so seems like there's going to be more logs coming out.
Okay. Let's get through all of this stuff, and then we'll try
to talk about it in its totality, all right? A little bit more
talking about it in totality after this. Sacramento goes offline
for 6 hours and immediately starts replying again the next day.
All right, we already read this post. So, picture up, lawyer
up. The court is neutral by design. You should make a steady
case if he indeed did hit you without consent or without warning
out of nowhere. Do not expect them or anyone to take your word
for it. Not because you are wrong or defective, but because that's
how legality operates. Do not expect miracles, nor the case will
go through in your or his favor. It may or may not be dismissed.
That has nothing to do with you personally. It's a
Thanks. Already been in contact with a lawyer cuz I know Tom
has, too. The difficult part of this case is the most most of
the proof is in his hands, i.e., the videos. So, we'd need to
get a subpoena for that if his sniffly hasn't figured out how
to get how to like perma wipe it yet.
I mean that's not hard to do. Okay, is that why he's been quiet
for a while? Has any other ex considered legal action against
him? Hello. If by quiet you mean social media and YouTube, he's
been quiet because he hates his job and too many people took
him out of context. I'm not sure if any other ex has, considering
his blackmail folder on Kai, but maybe.
I just remembered Laryx once contacted Jaylen and claimed to
have dirt on him. I'm waiting for Kai to come out cuz I know
she probably went through some crazy [__] cuz they
dated for 3 years.
That Kai girl's not coming out. I don't think that Kai girl's
going to start the fight with with with with like Tom's audience.
I don't think she's going to do it right now. Anyway, logs part
five. Just pictures of his [__] Just going to go
nuclear before his imminent crash out, but yeah, he would get
mad about me calling out our encounters rape play over tax, which
essentially they were was was Yeah, is essentially what they
were.
Something Holy moly, I love the
This is my basement. Oh wait, you're at your own house. Yeah,
not my parents', my house. I had to stop there to look around,
lol. I like the Despicable Me poster. The e-girl dungeon. Your
house is nice. It is nice. I don't miss it much, but it has its
epic epic moments.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, Tom.
The movie poster aesthetic.
The movie poster aesthetic. Bro.
Bro. Bro. Bro. Bro. All right, cool guy, what's your aesthetic?
Not looking like a total or who put puts movie posters up and
think they provide you like personality.
Like plants and neutral tones. Plants and neutral tones, okay?
That's what I do. Plants and neutral tones.
It's not much of an aesthetic, but it's something. It's a basement.
And this is Tom's personality. He likes all the meme movies about
cool guys. Seven's not really like that. What is this poster?
I don't recognize this poster right here. Why do I I feel like
I recognize Is it Back to the Future? It's Back to the Future.
I started asking then I'm like, "Oh, it's Back to the Future,
right?" And makeshift drapes. Okay, well you shouldn't know about
that.
I would keep that to myself. I would never share a picture of
that. I would never Okay.
Do not say times.
>> Dude. Do not say times. Okay, sorry. Change that to
consensual encounters, which is what they are. Thank you. I know.
But okay, sounds good. I'd like to, as I just said as as I said,
I just got to get work done, but I think I can still be there.
Okay, yeah. Okay, are you mad at me?
Dude. Okay, yay. What's going on with the economy? Don't worry
about it, kitten. Yay.
It's the It's the meme. Okay, yay. More proof that the girl he
sent nudes to was an H player.
Like, bro, I don't even know what you're saying to me. She looks
like a crazy person and dresses like a child. It's weird. It's
okay, though. I agree, she's weird and disturbed. I don't know
what to say. I was taking anything at the at that time. I got
no mutuals with her, unfortunately.
I'm just a little creeped out, but that's okay. I also got creeped
out, and she was nutso, so I stopped talking to
I think the problem with their relationship was that Tom didn't
stop talking to her. That genre of women are demons. Every one
of those types I've met like actually me up. I was friends with
one for a while, and she was insane and me over. Yeah, well,
this chick is insane, too. I feel bad for how bad her mind is.
So, shrug. She dresses like a kid. I think it's weird, no offense.
Yeah, I don't know what that's about.
I know I've had people come on to me because I look young because
I because I'm small, so it's weird.
Sorry for being cringe, but yeah, proof he was in contact with
her during our relationship. Just putting that out Can I read
this?
I know, but
come on to me because Oh, this is the thing about her being small.
It's previous line. Just putting that out there. All right. All
right. I don't know what you're trying to say to me. It's okay,
I'll drop it, lol. Well, that's good. I have some Aztec Mayan
magic in my mind. Am I crazy? No, but I don't like you being
judgmental and annoying about this. I'm not being either of those
things. Then what would you call it? Bro.
You don't like getting judged? How many subs do you get Tom and
Mr. Girl in here? Tom definitely is not joining. Tom would never
join. Okay.
I think Tom left the Discord around the time Nicholas left the
Discord. Actually, did Tom leave the Discord? Hold on.
I don't think I can get Tom in here, boys. I don't think that's
happening.
Let me see. From
Tom. Oh, misspelled that really badly. I
can't find. Nope. He I don't think he's there anymore. He's gone.
I don't remember when he's gone. Okay, anyway.
Just don't like you being judgmental and annoying about this.
I'm not being either of those things. Then what would you call
it? I don't know. I think I was just mad cuz I saw you texting
this girl nonstop when we hung out, and now I put a face to the
name, and it freaks me out that she's a weird like a weird
But I'm being annoying, you're right.
If I didn't have to talk to her, I wouldn't have, but I regret
even telling
about the situation that was unfolding now. Oh, so now he has
to talk to her cuz she like got hacked or something and her [__]
was getting posted, right?
That's why That's why he was texting her, apparently. I'm sorry.
So, next time I'll keep it inside. Anyway, I got to go work out.
Are you mad at me? A little bit, yeah. I just got up, and I'm
being hit with whatever this is. Oh, this is still continuing
on from when he first found out he was being hacked. I don't
know. I kind of understand why he's being like uh
I don't know, self-victimizing there, I guess. All right. So,
this is the little girl person. I'm guessing he was texting her
after he got hacked, okay? And to me
I guess maybe after he got hacked, I don't know thing like they
filing police reports along his with his other exes if he did
abuse you. Hanging around here too long rarely works out for
well for noobs. So, don't noobs who don't understand the site.
That's it. That's my only warning. Be careful. I'm working on
it now and asked Joshua for advice. Just trying to info dump
right now.
I remember he said for a while for him to get in a Sorry, it
takes a while for him to get a And then he has a body count of
three. Body count is 15 plus now since being two since being
two in March of 2024, according to Katie. Part of why I said
something. He's definitely being a weirdo with more girls because
he sleeps around.
He threatened to hit you with a in the head with a brick, too?
This is the I'm I'm Alex post. It's kind of funny.
Haha, no, but he was working on a video with this I'm Alex dude
the last time we spoke. Uh Is it really not uncommon for normally
women to screenshot Yeah, I can address
I can address Would screenshot my matches. This is talking about
Tinder when she matched with him. Would screenshot my matches
to document and put a face to the name. When I got a number,
not to be crass, but as a young young somewhat attractive girl,
you get a lot of matches, and it's hard to keep up. Also had
a feeling there was something about him. Yeah, I think cap. In
my opinion, cap. Total cap. Complete cap. Obviously
Yeah, but I don't know, whatever. Maybe, but I don't think so.
I think you're kind of just totally lying.
It is what it is.
One more thing to add I thought was odd. Never really expressed
any interest in Hello Kitty or that type of e-girl stuff. I had
like one Hello Kitty figure in my car as a gift. Tom bought me
Hello Kitty pajamas and a bunch of Hello Kitty stuff similar
to what Ellie / Creepy Hoarder wears.
Okay, at some point here when they're talking about Kai, we should
actually go to the Laryx stuff. So, give me a second cuz there
were some leaks, okay?
So, hold on. Let me go find the Let me go find the leaks.
Substance tweets. So, Aiden decided to start posting in his Discord
that essentially like um
[__] dude, I'm leaking it. Kai is into age play.
Lyrix told me when I when he first broke up with her. So,
this is another point of reference that according to Aiden,
Kai's into some age play [__] okay? Very weird.
That's Kai. This is the Turkey Tom's ex. So, this is another
point of reference for the age play stuff. Tom's also been doing
this stuff, okay? I do think
that this is Aiden piling on. And I do think that Kai probably
groomed this into him as well, okay? If I had to
Everybody knows this, but nobody wants to admit it. That most
guys, they get groomed by forces outside of themselves. Most
guys are pure of heart when it comes to sex when they first are
like spawned in, okay?
And it's either or a woman who groomed them into some crazy [__]
like choking women. Not even crazy, but like the more aggressive
stuff, okay? Guys aren't into that right off the off spawn.
That's not true, okay? Very often groomed into any kind of fetish,
all right? Men can do it, women can do it. Anyway, keep going.
Um Sorry, people are damning me. What is about Aiden is now to
age play [__]
Yeah, oh. So, another clip.
I don't know. Sorry, I just needed the screenshot. Cool.
Chad comments on the Aiden leaks. What did Chad say about the
Aiden leaks? Aiden immediately capitalizing on the Turkey Tom
leaks to push his own trauma out of the headlines is the most
thing I've ever seen. Bro, this picture of Aiden with the nose
is [__] up, man. That's crazy. You're all just vanilla?
No, I'm saying
>> I'm not vanilla. I'm not judging the the kinks of anybody.
Right? Queen confirmed he heard it before Aiden leaked it. Oh,
okay. Cool.
Cool, cool, I'm guessing Aiden leaked it at the commentary thing.
That's Aiden without his concealer on. Dude. Oh, I can see why
I can see why Aiden's wearing the makeup, okay? I got it. I got
it. I got it. That's a little crazy, dude. Um
No, I I think guys can do that stuff. They can be into it. I
just think it's women who introduced them to it. Or at least
that's Listen, that's my experience, okay? Like if a guy By the
way, a guy could do that in a relationship with a woman. I'm
just saying he was introduced to it either by or by another woman.
Okay? Women I paid off kept their end of the bargain.
>> Very funny. Very funny. Very funny. Oh, I should [clears throat]
go look at this Kilo post.
You guys see this Kilo meme floating
It's from Tom's interview with Aerodite,
Because to me, if you didn't even have consent to record the
video, then this is a whole different ball game. Like the it's
a whole different plan of action of like how I I'm going to process
what's going on. Right. But to your knowledge, you did have consent
to record, just not to share it. Um just to me like um recording
somebody and then without their knowledge and leaking it is like
like a full on like it's a it's a pretty like invasive crime.
Um leaking somebody's nudes I think is also really bad. To be
clearer, it is really bad.
But the issue is that I think it's I think it's fundamentally
more
Because to me, if you didn't even have consent to record the
video Unlucky. Unlucky. Dude, I got to go look at some of the
Miz clips of this. I I think I will probably go open up that
Miz stream at some point and take a look. Cuz I'm just I find
it so funny that Miz sits here being like, "I never watch a hit
piece." He like his girlfriend goes through the YouTube history.
He's watched like multiple.
she's like, "Oh, no. I watch these guys. I watch these."
Yeah, we'll we'll check it out. We'll check it out.
>> Oh, dude, the Alex Keko stuff was pretty funny, too.
Hold on. Oh, then the Kandros thing. Turkey Tom responds. Sorry,
I'm going through some memes really quick.
You guys
know who I am? I'm a good guy. Me? Diaper Max? You You guys know
me. I hate diapers. I'd never wear a diaper. What? Diaper Max?
I'm I'm I'm diaper minimizing. I've been on the diaper minimizing
movement for years. You guys know me. You guys know By the way,
that diaper thing, it turns out Tom, that was a whole meme on
his stream, the diaper thing, okay? It's a whole meme on the
stream. He ran with that [__] for a long time. A
long time. Oh, [__] Hold on.
All right. Sorry, I do want to just get through the rest of these
allegations overall before we move on to other stuff. And we
will move on to other stuff eventually here,
How's that looking? That's good. That's good. Okay.
So, somebody is responding this hor- horrifyingly ironic. Do
you have proof he purchased these for you? A message or gift
receipt or something? This is basically responding to I think
Tom bought her a lot of gifts.
I pictures of the stuff and a message I sent to my friend about
it. Okay, I can call you in a little whenever you're free. Yeah,
just call whenever I'm in the car. Okay. Oh my god, I need to
hear about Tom stuff. Oh my god, he pissed me off so bad, but
he said he got me Kuromi stuff for my birthday. Oh my god, girl.
He really the king of mixed signals.
Damn. What a crazy leak.
More responses, random responses. How is his family and his relationship
to them? His family was nice and normal, but he was rude to his
mom like in like an edgy 15-year-old boy way. Told me he wouldn't
do anything his parents asked because he has his own money now.
Katie heard him on the phone with my his mom and said the same
thing. Not sure what went wrong with his family because his family
super sweet and I enjoyed my time visiting with them. Also, would
drop the N-word casually in front of his family in front of his
parents, which was so weird, but I'm from the South, so maybe
it's different. I don't know.
>> Tom, we're just really worried about you. We're just
really worried about you. Shut up. The Tom I dude, why?
I don't know. Do you think that means hard R or soft A? I think
that means soft A. I can't see Tom dropping the hard R in front
of his parents.
Maybe soft A cuz you're very used to using it in conversation.
I can't see it being the hard R, man. Uh I noticed this as well.
He asked her about blue shorts after, which completely unrelated
Oh, I would say some people noticed that in the Miyatolin video,
in the Miyatolin video, I do believe that you see Tom basically
knowing what a bunch of the like little girl Japanese toy memes
are. Like he actually just knows them all. Like the Kuromi thing,
he know he noticed the Kuromi thing like right away. Is this
the timestamp or is this a different timestamp?
Do I look like your dog? No. You got to try something new while
we're here. And there's got to be like a unique toy that you've
been looking at you've been eyeing. Sorry, a shock collar. We
got to get a shock collar. >> Do you want to? Yeah. Okay.
Yes, we need to get one. What are they What's like the most one
with the most wattage? Let's get a beef stick.
It's somewhere in this video. It's a Hello Kitty thing. Yeah,
it's You're saying the Kuromi thing. Kuromi.
Dude, I can't find it in the in the transcript. God damn it.
Hold on. It's like they're walking through a store. Maybe I can
just find it.
They're at a different store. They're at like a store for like
figures and [__] Do they go to a different store
here?
The gym.
This will be where it is. I agree. You You wouldn't just say
that to hurt
Oh, no one came to the phone. Went to the annoying store and
everybody knew you. Can we hold that? Yes, please. Thank you
so much. I love when you say Kilo. Whatever. I I can't find the
timestamp. I had it before, but we lost it. We lost it.
We lost it.
>> Okay, we're here right here.
pretty sure Shirosa was her original username. She goes by a
few online, but Shiro US Shiro USA Shirosa is her most commonly
used. Show me the holes in the walls IRL on FaceTime, but didn't
get a pic. Told me he was paying the owner of the house he was
renting to get them fixed. I can send pictures of inside his
gamer room. This proves he is a true Oh, sorry. That is funny
knowing he respects her prostate, but racism free is a free game.
Wait, what? That is so funny knowing he respects her prostate,
but racism is free game. Such a weird
Just proves he is a true and honest queen that also likes his
partners lacking melanin.
How's the dirty sins on the desk? See, this desk was totally
fine.
Also want to clear something up that I don't have BPD, Katie
does.
Okay. Wow. This is already going really badly for this person.
This person shouldn't be responding this much. This person is
going to start seeking the approval of the people on this forum.
She's going to post more stuff. She's going to say more stuff.
It's not going to go well. It's not going to end well. I think
this is really bad already. I think like that's a thing you That's
the thing you try to clear up when you are seeking the approval
of people, right? I can already tell this not going to go well.
Let me just keep clarifying things about myself. Surely, they'll
all like me. Surely, this forum full of people on Kiwi Farms,
they'll all like me right away. If I can just clarify and make
sure they understand. They understand me, they'll like me, for
sure. No, they won't. Albert, before he tries to come at me,
I was open up up with the fact that fact to him very early on
that I was sent to a mental health facility twice prior to our
relationship because of depression and eating issues very early
on in our relationship. Would still continue to tell me how he
liked me or liked how small I am and feed into it. LOL. That
sounds bad, but
that seems like totally That seems like you could easily like
retroactively make that make that true in your head. You know
what I'm saying?
Like you would easily make that true in your head
if you wanted to. Okay.
Keep reading. Keep reading. Actually, more than anything, and
after quickly going through Ellie's Instagram, I think the Occam's
razor approach here is that Tom goes for the anorexic bulimic
type that probably also looks under age. Anyways, Sacramento
89, my main question here is as follows, and I think it's important
that it's answered. What convinced you going to Kiwi Farms with
this over leaking it on Twitter? This is where I found out all
of the sus stuff about him to begin with, and Joshua has been
kind to me, so I felt the So I felt comfortable posting. Yeah,
I think that's I just think, dude, you didn't know who You didn't
know who Null was. You didn't know who he was at all. What do
you mean you feel comfortable posting? You had no idea who Null
was. Shut up.
The [__] out of here, man. I'm sorry, but when I
heard Piles of Zinns, I was expecting some nasty hoarder [__]
You had me with text messages and stuff. I don't think two cans
of Zinns is is going to mean anything. This is on a good day
I swear it got worse. Was he possessive of you? We know Kyle
alleged he was controlling and jealous. No, he didn't give a
[__] Actually, in fact, he would get mad at me for
questioning his past. Okay, we got one more thing of logs here
between Clorox, Katie, and
Katie gave me permission to share her DMs, thought it might help
get the story straight a bit. Oh, both of their DMs. So this
is Clorox, Katie, and this girl. If it makes you feel better,
we hadn't talked in over a year. I met him twice in like February
2024. Okay, that's good. Okay. This is insane. You're a way way
better than him, girl. He was actually shockingly a gooner. He
recorded everything we did, which scared me. And also, he didn't
[__] the whole time, and I'm sorry to to TMI like
that, but I'm pretty shocked you were so
Basically, he told me not to research who he was, and when I
did find out this Kiwi Farms thing, and he got so mad. I had
the exact same issue. Oh my god, girl, I could tell you it all.
I used to be Kiwi Farms brained in a Kiwi Farm I used to be Kiwi
Farms brained incel 4chaner. I That's a sentence. I used to be
Kiwi Farms brained incel 4chaner.
Okay. So then we have some amount of time that's missing. Hold
on. Can I see 3:35 3:33?
Understandable.
Twin is hard to and Understandable.
Twin is hard to and scary, especially
with someone with any type of fame, and the fans are evil. Yeah.
He likes to hit and choke during And basically, I was bleeding
for days after. Yes, yes. Oh my god, twin, you are so seen right
now. I hope you know I
I'm sorry you went through that. Uh thank you I'm sorry you went
through
Thank you. I just needed someone to talk to. I understand. I'm
here for you. Anything you need, and I'll support you. Yes. Unfortunately,
his name is Tom. I'm a lesbian. Unless you talking turkey, Tom,
the Jimmy John's sub, then he got the wrong woman. Talking about
the Jimmy John's
What the [__] are they talking about? Yeah, sorry.
I
I don't text women who are like 20.
Thank god. Thank god. Thank Christ. I know Jimmy John's the restaurant.
This is just so out of place given what they were already saying.
Nice. You're too good for that Tom man, girl. I know we just
broke up. Uh he was talking to this Belle Delphine girl who's
going to leak his nudes, and he punched a hole in his wall. I
don't know when you last talked to him, but he's a mess. Who
is this? Tom who? Cuz that I've only spoken only man I've spoken
to named Tom. Wait, then what the [__] is going on
after this?
Bro, why are why are these messages Now she's like pretending
she doesn't know who this is. I don't even I don't even get it.
Did she post this out of order cuz the timestamps lead me to
believe it's in
Right? What the [__] are these texts? They're Katie
story archives.
Seeing Tom today. I'm not sleeping. I have to go to the airport
in 3 hours. And then 5 days later, so this is March 10th, 7:32
a.m.
March 15th, 2024, 4:03 p.m. And I still have this stupid bruise
on my face. Dump confirming identities of role player Ellie
creepy hoarder might help with timeline because he sent those
messages in August 2025, said the nudes were sent 2.5 years prior.
Katie will dump uh in a little bit. She's collecting info regarding
her trip to see Tom's injuries and sustained Tom's  injuries
sustained by him. She documented a lot more than me.
Who is Ellie L or whatever? What specifically are you talking
about,
When you ask me questions like this, it's extremely annoying
to me. You have to explain like, one, I saw this thing with this
person with you. Two, who are they? Instead of being vague, instead
of this vague way of asking about things, being vague drives
me up a wall. You can ask me a question, just be forthcoming.
I did ask too. You didn't ask tell me why you were asking this
or why it came up to you. You just said something out of the
deep blue sea. I have a sixth sense. I saw it in a dream. Speaking
of seeing things in a dream,
Candace Owens
had another stream recently where she talked about Charlie Kirk
and that he possibly saw his death coming. He possibly saw his
own future, okay? We will be checking that out later
We'll see.
Well, I'm not going to answer the question explain unless you
explain yourself. Uh is this the same one? Can I answer the question
unless you explain yourself? I saw her texting you a while ago,
Ben.
She's the girl whose photos were leaked with mine. So that's
what we were talking about. Oh, interesting. I get
If I could never speak to her again, I would. I don't hate her
or anything, but she's just some some chick I don't really care
that much about at this point outside of this particular thing.
I don't care either. I was just wondering. Dude, she clearly
cared a I don't care either. I was just wondering. I don't care.
I know I don't care. I I also don't care.
Oh, man, I need to stop the cap on my soundboard. Stop the cap,
bruh. I don't care. Hey, who's this girl?
Oh, I was just wondering. Oh, I Oh, I don't care. I don't No,
I don't care. I don't care. I don't care. I wasn't being a peeper
at all. You were texting her like half the time I was with you.
God forbid.
Women don't even care about guys. I mean, I guess they do, but
they'll date men with small I don't think anyone ever other than
OnlyFans girls will ever care will even care. #notme.
Wait, what is he saying?
Come on. Tom! Tom, stop! Tom! [screaming] Tom, don't talk about
your size in texts, Tom! Tom!
Tom, no!
Am I Is there any other way to interpret
I don't think anyone other than OnlyFans girls will even care
about size. He's talking about his pics being leaked. #notme.
Well, you're in a different cap, I suppose. Yeah, I mean, I don't
know. I pray that these people don't leak it. I think they did
already leak all of her DMs, and my is in there. So I'm expecting
it to happen soon. You sent in DMs? This is like 9/11. I did.
Instagram DMs. This was like 2 and 1/2 years ago. I don't do
this anymore. Get a load of this guy. Whoa.
I I feel like Isn't he saying I feel like combined they're saying
basically they're saying something about Tom, which is
Unlucky man. I do like that she just memes on him though. Get
a load of this guy.
Get a load of this guy with his out here. Get a load of this
guy. Okay. I am going to get out on a limb here, or sorry, go
out on a limb here and assume his phone was on off-limits, I
don't Did you have the password to it? Did he keep it away from
you or stop you if you tried to pick it up? Yes, didn't have
the password and never tried to pick it up cuz I knew he would
crash out. I'm not like this. I feel like I'm totally fine sharing
my phone. I like having my own password. I don't want anybody
going through my phone without it like without it being in my
possession, but I don't care if somebody's like concerned, I'm
like, whatever, I don't I don't have something to hide on my
Like it just does it doesn't bother me
I know people get jealous, and like I've been in relationship
relationships where I feel jealous, so I just I'm like, oh, I
don't want you to feel that way.
Like it's pretty not that not that big of a deal for me. For
somebody I'm in a relationship with who I'm like in close proximity
to. I can't imagine being one of those people who freaks the
[__] out when you when someone touches your phone.
I will say it weirds me out when other people are like that.
Anyway, yeah, okay. Uh splinter thread for users who are upset
that we are letting someone post internet drama on an internet
drama website without first receiving her medical paperwork to
see if she has BPD so we can know to completely disregard or
only heavily scrutinize her statements.
debate internet drama and internet drama threads. Null Null does
a lot of meta-genning, okay? I I think he he like does this a
lot where he gets really annoyed that people aren't talking the
way he wants to on the free speech the
Like they're literally like there is very strict moderation,
it seems, on the free speech forum.
I've seen this I've seen this in like multiple drama threads.
He'll just come in and be like, "Talk the way I want. Stop talking
this way. Talk the way I want." And it's like, okay. Okay, whatever.
I think most of Kiwi Farms
is like they don't like how Null moderates the board, but they
also know that nobody else would ever bother like keeping the
board up or doing all the things it requires to have the board
stay up. So they like him, but they hate the way he moderates
the board, I think, in a lot of cases. Uh this is really embarrassing,
but confirming aggression
I guess that's Sacramento again. Oh, Sacramento with these leaks
right
I'm honestly not that good. I have no natural athletic inclination,
but if you just keep doing it, it'll work. That's all there is.
I will. But in 2 years, that's impressive cuz you weren't you
a twink, and now you are a bear from bottom to top. You're really
strong because sometimes when you're on top of me and holding
my wrist, if I feel like my wrists are going to break in half,
I also feel like I've gotten used to
Uh used to the D becau- I also feel like I've gotten used to
the D because at first it used to hurt so much, but now it's
not so bad anymore. My bad, I shouldn't be so aggressive, but
you're like 100 lbs, so that's a part of it. It doesn't hurt
that much more so just or anymore, just at the beginning. I got
to get dressed and go to work. Get to work. Looking forward to
hanging out tomorrow though.
Okay, this is uh
That's I think that's like about it. Now, there's some other
fallout around
that we can go to, okay?
There's some other fallout here that we can go to eventually.
Quick quick preview of the Misgivings stream, okay?
What kind of calls himself Turkey Tom? I know, bro. We should
have known from the beginning this guy was a monster. He calls
himself Turkey Tom.
Disgusting.
I do. Anyway,
let's go through this, shall we, boys? Warning, these allegations
are bad, apparently. From what I understand, they're not good.
We are going to go through all the allegations together as a
family, okay? This is demon time. These are the kind of people
that attack me a long a lot. Turkey Tom made a video called Mizkif
has nowhere left to go, where it had 1.3 million views. I don't
even know what this video is about. I'm assuming you guys probably
watched it, and this video, I'm assuming Dude. Stop
the
cap. Oh, [__] Did we get donations? Oh, that's my
bad. I'm not watching donations. Soapbox Society, thank you so
much for the 10 gifted. Really appreciate it. Massive, massive
gifts. Thank you so much.
Dude, what is Miz doing? Oh, I forgot I shut my my donations
off. I'll turn donos back on now. Give me a second. Okay, donos
should be unmuted. Thank you so much, Soapbox Society, for the
10 gifted. Huge 10 gifted.
Open up the stream. Big time, big time. Twisted Rope, thank you
for the gifted earlier, as well.
I think we've got almost I think we've got the full 2 more hours
added to the stream. So, we're going to have lots of time to
go through. We could go We could cover the LSF stuff a little
Uh I think we have a no comment on the record from Stale, which
is unfortunate, okay? Very unfortunate.
Oh, thank you so much. Um Yeah, thank you so much, guys. So,
a couple people linked this. Ralph linked this. Another guy linked
this. Just to be clear, this is the very end of Nicholas Di Oreo's
stream. Now, there's another timestamp. Does anybody know where
this clip is? There is another timestamp
Di Oreo comes back from a break, and he's like rattled.
Does anybody have that timestamp or that clip? I would love it.
Thank you. Oh, just to be clear,
um
I have seen literally nothing of what's occurred tonight,
but my understanding
is that Half Baked is on hiatus for a little while. So, Half
Baked this is podcast with Turkey Tom. Um yeah, Half Baked is
his his hiat- his uh his podcast with Turkey Tom. Now, I will
say, it's kind of funny cuz I can look at I went and analyzed
those leaks and all of that stuff. I analyzed it through my own
lens, where I'm like, "Okay, I don't think you're really I don't
think there's much here that's like conclusively proved." I don't
um He went on a break to call Tom. Well, I think he did, and
he came back rattled. But, Half
Oh, I I've been giving you the analysis through my view, okay?
Which is I don't think a lot's proven about Tom. He's basically
like a dick degen in the way I expected. I I I think his actions,
in terms of like being canceled, are not
like it's not enough to cancel him here, right? You'd have to
prove out the the video recording thing. If he was If he does
this recording thing, like he should get a lot of heat for that.
He should be kind of like canceled for that or something. Like
non-consensual recordings [__] up. Shouldn't do that.
but there's no proof. There's nothing substantial beyond like
words from people. So, you'd need more people to come forward,
I think. As of now, I used my standard to go and say what I think
was wrong with this talk with with Tom.
Didn't she say he hated his job? She did say that, indeed. That
he hated his job, and that's why he doesn't post so much
with regards to how Tom
applies a standard to people, or how Tom and people like sort
of adjacent to him apply a standard, okay?
Those guys would outright be like I I swear to God, if if Tom
did a video on these allegations, and it was somebody else, the
word would be thrown around, okay? The word
A whole bunch of stuff like this would have absolutely been get
got getting thrown around all over the place, right?
They would have leaned into all of this [__] that
he like beats the [__] out of women. He's like a
violent I don't think that, but I do think it's important to
point out that Tom is not careful with how he covers stuff like
this very He has gotten details wrong. I do believe, with regards
to Mr. Girl, he actually got some fairly critical details wrong,
okay? To make him look more like a Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, and
that is also another point is that you the these people are kind
of letting it go. They're not posting about it. But, yeah, if
it was iDubbz, if it was Ice Poseidon, they would be all over
it. They'd be spamming posts about it all over the place. So,
yeah, it is what it is, man. Oh, am I the only one who Do I have
to go try to find this this like Di Oreo rattled clip? God damn
it.
Hold on. I have to I have to go see if I can find this Di Oreo
like rattled clip.
Where is this? Where is this? Where is this? Hold on. I should
try to find this really quickly because it's um Come on, no.
Man, there's more logs and stuff. We got a lot more stuff to
cover here. So, just give me a second.
We do need to go through more. I'm just looking for this clip.
It is critical we find it, okay?
I'll search this. We will see in the next couple days where that
goes. But, yeah, let's get some donos. So, I don't know if we're
going to do another uh I don't know what the deal is with that,
but I imagine not a lot of that for a little while. Oh, here
we go.
3 hours, 8 minutes. This is where he comes back from his [__]
okay? This is where he comes back from he like has a video playing,
3 hours, 8 minutes, and
40 seconds.
He's got a video playing, and he comes >> saw but all of
the major players were when Oh, this is This is a old vod of
his, by the way. He's away with an old vod playing. >> 100%
giving all of the context. I played the context at least five
different times across three different reaction streams, and
went through it. I even explained it.
Ethan watched it, explained it, >> Hey, guys. How is everybody
doing now?
Hello. [laughter] Hey, guys. How is everybody doing now?
How is everybody doing now?
Hello. What's going on?
>> Dude, it's 3 hours into your stream. You played a video
as you walked away. What do you think is going on? Dude, he is
so rattled, right? He is like so clearly
audibly rattled. I am back. I'm 100% sure he uses grok. I don't
know what the context of that was. That wasn't me speaking. Nick's
audio is so much better now. I think that was So, the difference
here Actually, can I tell you about something today? Augie reached
out to me and said, "Hey, >> Oh, but what? >> what
audio interface should I get? Cuz I'm going to stream soon, but
my audio interface died." And I said, "You should buy the Elgato
That's what I told him, the Elgato thing. I think it's called
the XLR
something, Wave XLR.
And what it [snorts] is is it's a button
Augie does need a better mixer. What the [__] was
going on with Augie's audio the other day? I watched some Augie
stream. He's going through the Aiden stuff.
And what the [__] was going on with his
Bro, he went robotic He He went robotic like a hundred times.
I don't get why he's at second angle, either. I thought that
was cool, the above angle. I thought that was cool that like
if you want to do like an end of stream sort of like lean back.
That was fine.
Mic was way too compressed. He needs better EQ. I don't know
about that. He's an amateur. Well, anyway, so he comes back totally
rattled there. It's a little funny. All right. And then he goes
on He goes to his Discord.
Dude, the Discord memes are funny. A very, very
dedicated
and respectful Nicholas Di Oreo fan actually set up
a whole website
that just basically takes Nicholas Di Oreo's Discord and and
posts all of the Discord messages to a publicly viewable
log. This is a very dedicated fan of this website.
See, look at the bottom, it says uh made by made with love by
a long-time Nicholas Di Oreo fan. There's like a fan of his who
decided, "I'm going to make a webpage that takes Nicholas Di
Oreo's Discord and actually puts it all out on the web and archives
it for everybody." You fan. You fan. What the Can we get some
very poggs in chat? Hello. I need some very poggs. I need very
poggs stat. Go Go arm your very poggs, okay? I wish I had a fan
who would who had this kind of initiative, who just start like
community projects
like this. It's so It's so awesome. Anyway, soy community drama
is where all of the posts are going, which I believe is what
this qualifies as. Soy community drama. Anyway,
so from there, we're taking a look at
where we going next? I think we're going to Nicholas Di Oreo
and his Discord logs, okay? Right after this.
Let's take a quick look. What did What did our friend Nick have
to say in his Discord, okay?
Is what he said right after the stream?
Okay. Oh, I want to pop this back up to be perfect. Yep, okay.
I obviously been streaming all night, so I'm going to probably
dig into it tomorrow. Fair warning, for obvious reasons to talk
about the Tom stuff. For obvious reasons, I don't feel like I
am a super able to be super impartial here, regardless. But,
that may actually That may change when I look into the what he
actually did. In the meantime, this topic can be moved can be
here or moved into #dramatalkchat.
No restrictions.
Okay, so he says, "Talk about this all you like."
By the way, I will say
I get the feeling he didn't cover it
I think, in terms of the allegations that they'd actually cancel
Tom for, that these guys would like disavow Tom for, I don't
I think proof's really light on those. Like there is still a
chance that these these people are like trying to create a narrative
with very very very little. Just the fact that they like met
met Tom, they knew Tom. Right? They [__] Tom. It
is That is possible. There's a real significant chance of that
still. Like I Seriously, the thing there's probably an equal
or better chance that this is like kind of made up or compounded
to damage Tom's reputation to to not really like say much, but
to maximize reputation damage, and and just be yeah, that he's
not really that bad a guy. He's just like kind of weird.
I will say if it's all true, then it is bad. But just in terms
of the the proof, it's light on the ground. So, there's a chance
that some of this is made up. There's a chance that some of it
won't really stick at all. And there's probably a higher chance
of that than the idea that this woman had no idea about like
YouTubers, commentary YouTubers, or Kiwi Farms, or any of that.
I I truly believe that that was an obvious lie.
So, happy hunting half-baked obviously on hiatus is their next
message there. I'm guessing that's pretty close. I'm so
>> Wait, what is this? I said Who's this? Why is this guy
here?
I'm so confused at his comment reading into why the podcast is
on hiatus. He knows I was live streaming for the majority of
the time that thread was being written slash discussed, right?
Wait, who is he talking about here? Do we know?
What's the response?
Is this talking about Chud? It must be talking about Chud, right?
Yeah, okay, okay. Cuz he is talking about Chud I know a lot in
this whole conversation thread.
You guys don't get how funny this is, lol. Chud said himself
he's going to melt it. I really don't. I had a falling out with
Chud literally around 2:00 p.m.
Oh, damn. Nothing serious, and I'm not going to litigate it,
but wow, today's take seems a little more critical. Haha.
So, I'm having a thought.
Maybe it's not the New Year's stream.
Maybe it's just New Year's. Maybe not doing the New Year's stream
does not prevent the New Year's.
Wow, so cool.
I I think Chud's been slowly trending in this direction. Like
it's so funny that they see it they don't see it like the correct
way, right? That Chud was sort of
I don't want to be I don't want to be like critical cuz I like
far be it for me to be critical of this, but Chud was kind of
soft sweeping and not being overt and and kind of you know, harsh
in his criticism before. Like that that's kind of a soft sweep
on his end. And I think when when he finally does kind of burn
the bridge with this guy, if they do have like a falling out,
I got to imagine it's like, "Dude, I did everything right. I
like I tried to help. I tried to be like kind to you. I tried
to I tried to tell other people not to go hard on you.
And then you just burn me anyway. Like you refuse to talk to
me. You just kind of like gave me the cold shoulder. Like what
what else did you want me to do? Has to be how Chud felt, right?
Accuses Chud of sweeping till it was convenient inconvenient
for him. Well, it's not that it's inconvenient. It's that like,
"Hey, I was like I was probably being overly kind to you because
we were friends and you helped me out with my channel and all
this and like I had a relationship with you. I was probably like
more kind to you than you actually deserved. Like if I was just
being brutally real with you, I would have [__] on
you pretty hard
this might not even be wrong from Nicholas, but he's looking
at it like, "Oh, it's [__] up that this guy wanted
to stop sweeping. It's like [__] up that this guy
was angry because I didn't respect his sweeping or something.
It's like, dude, I don't know. Were you friends or not? If you
weren't friends, he should have covered it and he was [__]
up. If you were friends, then I don't know. Why didn't you treat
him like a friend? There is a chance that Tom is the subject
of an op by all of his exes. There's a chance that Tom is a But
even if it is an op, all of his exes banding together to accuse
him of [__] doesn't bode well for his boyfriend qualities.
Well, it's not all of his exes though, Klein Hila. It's two of
his exes, one of whom he only met twice
over the course of 2 months or something. I think I think it
was twice. So, it's two of them saying he's like rough during
sex, which like I get. Like it's standard porn like yeah, standard
porn addiction
And that seems to check out like that seems to I don't know,
feel accurate to me. I'm not shocked by
I don't know if that's like cancelable.
Maybe it should be, but it's it's difficult when it's like, "Oh,
it's months later with with the one of them, right? It's like
14 months later, 15 months later. But again, I will say it's
very obvious to everybody.
Uh no, Brazilian lot I I've none of those
I I've none of those issues.
But I will say that's my standard.
Their standard
is way different and by their standard, they'd blow Tom up as
a By Tom's standard, he'd get blown up as for having all those
DMs with that that kid core girl for
like all of the all of the childlike characteristics. By their
standard, they'd be calling him a Look at some of the messages.
You guys are You guys go crazy. By the way, like I would say
you should have seen Chud's chat not understand the foreplay
thing. Yeah, when when she said she was bleeding, I'm like, "It
sounds like you just went in dry." That's what it sounds like
to me. Like he just doesn't understand how to have sex with people
such that they want to to repeat the experience. If you're a
fake girl, do you actually get to call the men you date Well,
I don't think the main girl, the Sacramento girl, wasn't a fake
girl. And actually the other one wasn't really either. I don't
think the other one was at all. So,
I don't think so. Even with prep, three three rough times a day
is bad?
three rough times a day?
No. No. I disagree. I would say it's bad if you're like slapping
somebody in the face, sure.
But like no, I don't think three times having rough sex three
times in a day is necessarily bad. I don't I don't think that's
that tough. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like not Yes. Yes. Rough is in
like yeah. I mean, on a consistent basis, yes. I'm just saying
there's nothing wrong with that. If that's If that's like your
libido and you're going to do that, you're like good with it,
it's
I'm not Yeah, I'm I'm not somebody who is doing that on a regular
basis. I would say the second girl, by the way, had significantly
harsher condemnations of how rough he was during sex.
Right? Like significantly harsher. Like way way harsher. She
was crazy. All right, I think we're basically done all the Salvo
memes.
Uh were there good Salvo memes?
See what Salvo had to say about this. What did Salvo have to
say about this?
Listen, I've been studying Oh, final take of the Turkey Tom drama.
Probably don't want that one first.
Salvo brigades DeOrio.
See what's going on here.
I know Salvo was live
He's live right now. So, he's live and he's not even willing
to >> even talking Fungus said raw. Next question. Ian
Sharp said, "No, Mom, I >> How is this live right now and
not talking about Turkey Tom? How does that make sense?
Uh I would say most people
going to go and start reading the live leaks off of Kiwi Farms
as it happened. That's like not most people. Most people don't
want to do that. Most people are like, "Hey, huh I'm not with
my like huge channel going to go and just read word for word
bar for bar off of KF. I'm probably going to
on his chat. >> Get in there. Nicholas DeOrio, get in there.
Make it about the Tom situation. >> he not talking about
Turkey Tom? This isn't Twitter. Get your
group chats up. He's live right now and not talking about the
biggest commentary
What world are we living in? >> called Ultimate Vape Review.
What world are we living in? should be Well, we could become
best What world are we living in? Amazing. Okay. Uh we've got
one and then the other here today. This was yesterday. >> young
men on the internet in many Salvo's final take. What's he say?
>> Listen, I've been studying young men on the internet
in many spheres
of online for about 4 years now, probably going on 10 if we truly
think about it.
These young men are addicted to
at the age of like 10 years old through their adolescence into
their young adult men life. That's what it comes down to.
Every like YouTube internet streamer video maker, their demise,
their public humiliation deserved, and they know it, too. Deep
down they know it's deserved. That's why they're doing any All
right. Good stuff. Good stuff. Good stuff. Good stuff.
All right. I think I'll check and see. Hold on, there's a memes
page. I'll see if there's other good stuff in the memes. See
what else we got. Oh, I'm going to go do the Mischa stuff for
Hold on, we're going to do more of the Mischa stuff. Give it
a second. Da da da Chud logic and DeOrio falling out. Slumpy
Willy tweets. Oh, hold on. I'm Alex's You So, this is getting
auto posted today. YouTube's first performative male, I'm Alex.
>> was completely destroyed when his ex I don't know if
Tom's allegations are significantly worse than I'm Alex's. >> girlfriend
published one single clip. But truly, his reputation was never
Uh the unfortunate thing for Alex is there's a lot of evidence
of Alex's allegations. That's it's Look, it's very
Very very different.
What is Rhinox posting? What's Rhinox
never built to last from I already want that guy like executed
after his presidency, so I I I really can't get any more aggressive
about how I want that person treated. >> carelessly harming
his Okay, hold on. We're here for the comments though, okay?
We're here for the comments. That's what we're here for. Live
by the slop, die by the slop. Tom the kind of guy to have performative
male issues in the Oh, no.
Oh, no, dude.
Oh, that's rough. Turkey Tom, YouTube's last performative
This comment section going to be crazy.
Turkey the type of guy to post through the allegations in 2026.
Click the video exclusively for the comments. Sir, a Score Index
girlfriend has hit the KF thread. Dude, actually,
it's two. I don't think it's going to stop at two.
Especially with how much Kai is referenced. You think Kai says
nothing?
I'd say 80% chance Kai says nothing, but that's like a lot. That's
a big chance that Kai says something, right?
Elephant address me. Wait, ex-girlfriend leaking info, that reminds
me of someone. It's so funny that he did an Alex video, dude.
It's so funny that he did an Alex video on like the day like
the day after those allegations dropped. That's crazy.
This video has been done for weeks, scheduled for release, and
it comes out at the worst part. Yeah, exactly.
This video was like scheduled for
That's rough timing. That is rough timing, man. Mentioning Belle
Delphine in this video after them texts came out as crazy work.
SpongeBob me boy.
Oh, for some for anyone wondering the drama is TLDR his exes
come out alleging he would film them without their consent during
deeds. He has engaged in age play people he's with not with not
him. And would be only be able to finish things himself by watching
those clips of them together.
More was mentioned, won't go into it But these are not proven,
very minimal screenshots. We don't even know if it's his real
ex, but they do have chats with them, that's for sure. So, we
are waiting for a response from either him from either from him
to either confirm or prove it's this prove this is all fake,
Jesus.
Bro really took his friendship with Destiny to heart.
You know why you're here. He built the very tower he would fall
from brick by brick. I like that. I like that comment. He built
the very tower
he would fall from. In saved by Yahweh. Never, ever, ever, okay?
Anti-semitism
is the most effective
uh what would you call heuristic in the world, but it has to
be positive anti-semitism, okay? The Jews will prevail. I have
faith, okay? That the Jews are God's chosen people and they will
prevail, no matter what. No matter
You You want to bet against the Jews? Oh, I'll take that bet.
What are you betting against them in? Oh, I'll take that bet.
You want to bet against the Jews? No, the Jews are going to win
in the end, okay?
You think Aiden's getting canceled? Nah.
No, I don't think so. Where's the StreamElements link? {exclamation
point} donate is the is my StreamElements. It's Streamlabs, but
the Streamlabs and Kickbot links there. You can use either one.
I got to just casually post a main channel video, Tommy boy.
You have bigger fresh fish to fry, bud. So, I'll remind you guys.
Hold on. You guys also need to understand
that there seem to objectively be leaks out there
of Tom that is
Tom's pics
that have been draw have had attention drawn to them
that I've never heard about getting
It seems like to me
that's like a big tactical you from the ex, right? That she's
talking consistently about how he had these leaks come out only
recently. Like this person was only hacked recently, it seems
like, and he put a hole in his wall. That's sometime
since I think it's August 2024.
Sorry, August 2025.
Right? So, it seems like there's more people with more leaks
about Tom, and she's drawing attention to it, sort of making
like a lightning rod to that Kiwi Farms thread saying like, "Hey,
go post more stuff."
Little spooky for him right now. This is Tom is on
Defcon 2, okay? Maybe maybe even Defcon 1. It's It's Defcon 1
for Tom right now.
Nuclear war is imminent.